The dragon's mouth and this thing.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
And we're laughing.
Oh,
okay.
Gentlemen.
Hello.
Let's do have the ability to go live.
That's nice.
Oh yeah.
You guys have.
Fuck.
You will lose.
You get fucked by Mr Rogers.
Mr Rogers.
It's funny,
the Bob Ross Estate.
Mr. Over the age of 19 dream,
but this is what's confusing what most
of what you guys do in terms of like the
Bob Ross thing in particular.
First of all that was,
that took a lot of balls because this is
a.
You had Bob Ross Painting Muhammad,
which is a period blood.
The second one because they,
the buzzfeed women were doing the
painting.
It was youtube actually after meeting
with Youtube.
Remember how you can top something
because we'll,
we'll pull this sucker right up to.
There you go.
It's almost like an additional seven and
our student,
you know.
Um,
but yeah,
we were Bob Ross estate got after you.
But,
but that's parody.
How can they mock you or how can they
get you in trouble for mocking something
or doing parent,
here's why.
You have a system with youtube right
where they just strike,
they strike you and you lose your
privileges whether you win or not.
We've never lost.
So the Bob Ross,
the state sent us a message right into a
thing like first off,
have you no decency,
you know,
this isn't in accordance with Islamic
law.
Laughing our asses off onto this lot
like you're supposed to be in accordance
with Islamic law when I'm doing.
Because they thought that we didn't know
that it was a fence.
Yeah,
they thought we didn't know.
We stumbled across this and so then we
bonded to the lawyers as Bob Ross would
have on let's say,
welcome back to the joy of painting.
We're going to draw her lawyer friends
eating from a nice big pile of shit and
we painted them eating from a pile of
corn infested shit and then at the end
of the video and it looks like they need
a friend and put Muhammad right next to
them in the pile and it hangs above our
bathroom and we never heard from them
again.
They sent a cease and desist and we,
we ran it past her lawyer.
Shocking me have killed.
Yeah.
So,
and now we have Mr Rogers now.
What is Mr Rogers mad about?
We did a parody.
We did a few parodies of uh,
you know,
won't you be my neighbor intros.
That was it like a year ago.
But again,
how,
how could someone put a strike on you
for a parody?
I mean,
I thought that is protected.
Well,
you know,
you get to the realm of parody and
satire and it's.
But,
but even then it depends on who looks at
it.
That's the problem with Youtube,
right?
Just someone.
Last time we got her privileges back,
this time we didn't like.
We were like,
listen,
we've never lost a case.
We've countered filed.
We've always won.
This is clearly parody.
The Mr Rogers was actually your brother.
You want to track each like their,
their,
their logos there.
Nothing.
Nothing humps aboriginal.
Yeah.
No.
Here's what's fucked up.
You were telling me about a meeting that
you guys had when you went to New York
for Youtube.
They were comparing like what?
What is demonetized and what's not
demonetized and they had something that
would,
you just explained what happened?
We,
we don't exactly know because it's
boiler plate answers,
right?
We get brought out a bunch of
conservatives get brought up to New York
who like,
who is worthy with you?
We'll us,
you know,
the daily wire people who were really
cool.
You Know Ben Shapiro's guys forward
publishings and then a bunch of tanks
mostly and everyone sat there and played
nice and they bring out this whole
spread.
They bring into the Google offices,
give you,
give you a tour.
This is in New York.
Do they fly you out or they ask you to
fly in,
fly out the paper that pay for the whole
day.
They favor the whole thing but you up?
Yeah.
Goes this summer.
Was it summer
six monitor half Asian lawyer.
Bill came with us and they didn't know.
We just were like,
Nah,
he's a producer.
He came out and read the sitting there
right next to it,
the whole thing voted number one lawyer
in the state and a hilarious,
really funny guy.
So we go out there and we're just
sitting there kind of listening and
they're just saying nothing.
And finally I said,
well,
you know what's happening with
demonetization?
What's happening with.
Obviously we're all conservatives here.
Everyone.
We've had our videos put in restricted
mode.
What are the guidelines?
We don't know and they wouldn't.
They're like,
that's a very good question.
And they looked at the back because it
was later in the day elephant in the
room as if it wasn't obvious.
That's why.
That's why everyone's there and that's
what happened.
That's was the period blood spirit.
They're like,
well,
you know,
things that are hate speech,
things that could be offensive,
things like current events,
it can be controversial and so
everyone's sitting there.
Yeah,
but I just said where I said what about,
what about buzz?
People have been painting in period
blood and the trending feed painting in
last week and viscously chunky period
lead on the home feed that's on youtube
training.
What about that?
Is that considered like child friendly
and conservatives were.
Then they're looking back.
I was like,
look,
we were ruining the movie.
I'm saying like,
why are we here?
You know,
that's the problem.
People don't say anything.
Well that is a very valid discussion.
That's valid.
Like what if you can't have been.
If you can paint in period blood and I
don't think you should be restricted.
I think if you want a pain period blood
as long as I know what you're doing.
It says painting a period.
Well,
the title it was,
it was an adult.
Well,
I might actually watch it,
but here's the thing.
These women,
I might,
I might just for this to boldly channel,
but the porn is like,
hopefully I don't want to take that
right away from them,
but I just.
I'm confused by what.
What is.
Okay,
what's not okay?
You can't.
They embolden the right.
If you silence them,
you embolden the left.
If you silence bold people,
when you say you,
you give them power,
you,
you make the whole thing bigger than it
has to be.
People are allowed to have differences
of opinions and they're allowed to have
different ideologies,
but when you have a platform where you
radically restrict one ideology and you
openly support another one,
you're picking aside what's kind of like
dinesh d'souza talks about.
It's not about the law is,
is is it applied equally?
Right.
Youtube doesn't even respect the laws.
Here's something can happen with
youtube.
Just to give an example,
people have to a lot.
I don't know this,
so there's no single party consent.
State two party consent state.
California is one of the few states
where you have both.
People have to know they're on camera.
Now.
Even sometimes in a two party consent
state,
there's no reasonable expectation of
privacy if you're at a public event,
right?
If you're a public protest,
you can't say,
hey,
you can't take my picture.
You're there publicly protesting.
So these are legal layers,
right?
We had someone in a single party consent
state in Michigan on camera,
at a public protest sign,
a release to give an interview and then
complained to Youtube and said,
I don't want to be in that video.
It didn't matter that we presented the
law,
the paperwork to youtube.
It was taken out.
We had to blur the face.
But did they look bad?
Was,
was it under false pretenses?
Like did they think that you were doing
one thing and then you're really doing
something else?
So the crazy thing is this actually was
a guy who agreed with them almost
everything.
Yeah.
He was talking about that last minute.
He was really pissed about,
well,
you know what?
He probably just got a lot of feedback
and was like,
well,
this is freaking me out.
I want to get out of this.
Yeah.
But as a content creator,
you can't be like,
well,
sorry,
I didn't like it.
We don't know.
I mean,
you can understand like his perspective,
like him trying to get it taken down.
If you're a general public person and
you don't know what the fuck you're
doing,
you say something,
you don't put it on him.
He realized later he was raped.
It was much later taken down.
Now,
um,
I feel like when you,
when you pointed out the whole period
blood thing,
painting and period blood,
what?
Dead Silence.
No one said anything.
They didn't respond to you.
And then leaders.
That's a good question.
We'll get to that later in the day.
So later in the day was when they came
up with this next Gen news and we were
like,
it got to a point where I was hissing
ourselves.
Explain this because you explained it to
me earlier.
The problem is right.
We have,
I have to be careful because otherwise
they'll take it out of context.
So then this is the newest portion of
the day,
this whole Youtube conference bringing
out conservatives and you know that the
salmon a plate,
which I don't think there's anything
gross or he was eating pasted fish in
the car.
No way here.
It was quick and delicious.
So I think it was a next gen news for
evolution.
I always get it wrong or whatever.
I think it is,
is the opposite side.
I think it's next year we'll go next to
the lawyers would completely advocate
against.
We're doing,
we're giving such specificity.
So this is the exact channel.
It's like hip hop and sneakers,
sneaker hall with whatever the guy from
the show,
blackish,
anthony,
whatever.
That kind of stuff.
So it's a lot of hip hop news.
So they come out to teach us how to do
news and they will sell before we show,
you know,
so and so from extend news,
the sizzle reel and every other word is
the Edward m effort.
And you could see them looking back and
they turn it down because it's the whole
channel is.
They didn't screen that.
No,
they didn't screen it and she comes out
and he's talking about news and how to
create content.
The Algorithm,
knowing your audience,
knowing your audience is the content
creators.
She's like the founders of it,
I guess
complaining you're filming someone going
through sneakers.
I mean,
I don't want to content it is.
And then I just said,
yeah,
you know,
at this point they've been saying we're
going to get to news all day.
This is the first time someone's come
out because.
Yeah,
question.
Um,
we just heard about the new guidelines
and now she wants to beat advertiser
friendly.
It's supposed to be family friendly,
a consumer that you deal with hip hop
and a lot of pretty,
pretty adult,
pretty profane content.
Have you been hit by at the time was
called the apocalypse.
I said,
if you've been hit by this.
And she said,
no,
not at all.
I said,
okay,
no further questions that,
that's amazing.
So all of that stuff's fun.
It's fine.
It's just,
it's about the wrong opinion.
That's really what it comes down.
But is it fine because they're black,
but she wasn't black.
She wasn't black.
She was a white girl.
I think she was black.
Really?
Yeah.
Well I don't see color.
Me saying that.
I'm Irish quarter.
I've been talking about this like I more
Irish
than a lot of people that call
themselves black.
I'm one quarter Irish,
three quarters Italian,
but if you look at me,
I look mostly Italian,
but if I said I'm an Irish man,
people will be like,
wait a minute.
Are you really?
She was like Abercrombie and Fitch.
Black.
Yeah,
black.
She's generically ethnic.
Okay.
Like if I were a guy,
you know,
he didn't have no problems with them
dating your daughter if you were kind of
a racist.
They knew that it was a pretty slide
intimidate everybody,
but if she went to like a really fucking
heavy duty hip hop place and start
throwing that word around,
they would look at it like,
Hey,
she even allowed to say that.
Can you go blurting out the n word when
you that white?
I didn't know that she could do it with
her sizzle reel.
Well that seems like a bit of a problem.
Right?
That's like one of those weird double
standard rules in terms of like the
language,
like if you are in that community,
you're allowed to use what is otherwise
extremely offensive language.
Yeah,
sure.
It's like you have to have a hood pass
to use it,
but you like the Platinum version?
Yeah.
So really all the way to get a black
what?
Especially on Youtube.
I mean I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with using that language.
Well,
I had a conversation I told you about
this,
that I had a conversation with this
woman from Youtube and one of the things
that we were talking about was
demonetization and we were talking about
like why things get flagged and I was
talking about a conversation that got
flagged on Jamie.
What is it called when someone
recommends something and they have it in
their feed,
like their preferred playlist,
like a regular person,
not a content creator,
but if they have it on,
on their,
you know,
you could do that.
You can have it in your channel.
Like you could I think just like
suggested playlists.
It's their algorithms.
So what it's called you,
you would call it a but not their
algorithms,
like you would pick it,
like say if I've watched one of your
video video on Bob Ross and I liked it,
what would it in your queue cut that
kind of.
Is that what it is?
The q?
Yes.
Okay.
So this guy,
gosh,
I feel like we're really stupid right
now.
Like none of us just got that one
simple.
We're all on youtube too.
Stupid asses.
But um,
so this guy got flagged and it was just
a conversation between Sam Harris and
some other guy.
I forgot who he was,
was an intellectual and it was about
left wing culture and it was about
leftwing radical ideology and they were
criticizing it and this,
this got his channel flagged.
And I was like,
well how is this possible?
And she's like,
well,
he's advocating that people watch this
and it must promote hate speech.
I'm like,
I fucking guarantee you that doesn't
promote hate speech.
Did you guys even watch it or does
somebody else complained about it and
flag it?
And then I brought up Jordan Peterson.
And by the way,
it was just here,
just left.
He's going to be on their show there
next week to Canada
and she said like,
he's a problem.
He's a bit of a problem.
He's a troublemaker.
I'm like,
he's a troublemaker.
I go with because he has his own
opinions on things like what is going
on?
Like what,
what are you guys promoting?
A very specific ideology and anyone who
differs
from that is hate speech because we're
getting crazy.
If that's the case,
I think a lot of them don't know.
Here it is.
Oh,
is this it?
Yeah.
Douglas Murray Hill.
Look,
I can see it over there now.
Community guideline strike for just
listening to an honest intellectual
conversation between Sam Harris and
Douglas Murray.
Who is the guy who got.
Who got it?
Dig it down.
Yeah.
The S,
p e t e R K CCX.
He's very bold.
Yeah.
So this is a community guideline strike
for come by the way I listened to that
conversation between Sam Harris and Doug
Murray.
Douglas,
sorry Douglas.
Um,
there's nothing offensive about it.
It's just a,
they're discussing things.
Well,
here's the thing is now we've scaled it
backwards.
There's nothing if even if there were
actual video,
what that is and find out what the title
of it is and if maybe there's some sort
of a description.
Does it say what does it say?
They're just as Sam Harrison Douglas
Murray.
Yeah.
I forget who Douglas Murray is,
but click on him.
See if you can click on him.
A strange,
strange death of your.
Okay.
Ima Immigration Identity Islam.
That's what it is.
So Douglas Murray is a.
He is critical of the open border policy
that you're seeing become very
problematic in some parts of Europe and
by the way,
which is funny because Sam Harris is
against the wall against Donald Trump's
wall,
so it's like that's just two people
probably with differing opinions on that
issue to some degree.
Sam Harris is a pretty noted critic of
Islam,
but I think.
No.
Yeah,
but I mean the immigration thing,
he's more.
He's more open borders in the states
then a guy like that.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well,
I think what he's essentially saying is
they're talking about the very real
issues that they're dealing with in,
in Europe and youtube size.
Yeah.
When we played a video the other day of
Paris of some parts of Paris that
immigrants who have moved into and just
fucking completely wrecked.
I'm not anti immigration.
My grandparents were immigrants,
but I'm just saying that there's a real
issue and this guy,
Douglas Murray was discussing this real
issue with Sam Harris.
That got flagged and it got labeled as
hate speech.
Like.
Well,
I had a fucking crazy man.
It's weird.
I had a friend,
Lee Dorn,
so he actually,
he graduated like a,
like a University of Michigan Law.
Really just brilliant,
brilliant guy.
He's like a Shapiro Kinda guy and he was
one of the early,
early youtubers,
early adopters,
first other conservative on Youtube.
Very Analytical,
very,
very dry,
very smart.
And he did a video that was.
It was just called something like the
Japanese were not the victims in World
War II and it was a video about the
atrocities that the Japanese committed
against the Chinese.
That's all it was.
Like the rape of Nam King,
why would he didn't get yes,
but he didn't get super graphic,
but he was basically talking about like,
people just look back and I look at
Hiroshima,
but let's actually look at the
aspirations of the Japanese empire
historical.
It was removed as hate speech and here's
the thing.
He came to me and because we had those
contacts at Youtube,
we were.
They immediately apologize and fixed it,
but what worries me is what if you don't
have a million plus subscribers.
Right.
You know,
what if I weren't there for him and
that's the one thing that I always get
worried about with comedy and with a lot
of entertainers is they,
they kinda pave a path and sometimes
these guys,
I closed the door behind him like,
well it was okay for me to say it,
but now this is,
that's really,
I've learned better.
We should say,
well hold on a second.
We're in the boat.
Were you were,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
and there's a lot of famine thinking
going on in that regard where people
automatically want to protect what they
have and get nervous about it and they
forget what got them there in the first
place.
What makes any of us popular is the
ability to express yourself online in a
way that resonates with other people
that are listening now.
As soon as you restrict that,
as soon as you change that and say,
well,
you know,
I just want to do real good and I'm
making a lot of money now I'm going to
change who I am.
You're fucked.
I would take it a step further and say,
authenticity and people like you because
you're authentic.
Yeah.
I think we're pretty authentic with what
we do with the show.
I mean,
we're pretty straightforward.
Um,
people come up and they meet us at shows
and they're like,
wow.
It feels like a right.
You can't,
you can't be authentic and play by
youtubes rules unless you completely
agree with them.
So it doesn't have to agree with them.
You have to be authentically willing to
abide by.
So that's the whole thing.
There's no authenticity.
It's like regardless of the rules that
they claim,
which are so ambiguous in practice,
there's no way to make it work.
Well,
I think this is indicative of the
ideology that radiates throughout
Silicon Valley,
which is radical left progressive,
Neil Marxist sort of ideology and
there's so much of that going on
throughout silicon valley,
so much in the tech community.
So much uber progressive thinking,
which,
you know,
look,
I think all of it comes from the right
place.
I think they all want no racism,
you know,
they want no hate speech,
they all want wonderful things,
but you can't just decide arbitrarily
what is and isn't based on your
perspective.
You,
you have to look at it,
honestly.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't think they're doing that.
I think when you look at that Douglas
Murray,
Sam Harris thing,
and the guy getting,
getting a community strike for just
liking it.
I mean this is crazy.
This is the.
They take an authoritarian approach to
solving the whole thing,
which and they refuse to accept the
results,
which is the Donald Trump presidency and
they've created so in their defense.
One of the things they did say to me
that the problem that you're dealing
with people,
the problem with they're dealing with is
blunt tools.
They're saying these tools that D
monetize things,
they're not good yet and she said within
the next six to eight months,
they're going to get better bullshit
working on them.
I don't know,
second,
but let me look.
Let me just express her perspective.
She was saying that they have made
significant strides since they first
started doing it and they're getting
better at it.
They're getting better at isolating and
one of the things we discussed is those
fucking creepy cartoons,
you know,
I'm sure you've seen them as a child
molestation stuff.
Well,
the,
the violent stuff,
a lot of it like babies getting hit by
bottles.
Have you seen those?
Yeah.
Those things.
I've watched good things.
You know,
we're talking about now that I'd never
seen it all.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a weird thing where these things
get put on a kid's playlist,
you know,
it's like Mickey Mouse and Minnie miles
getting drunk
and then like someone throws a bottle up
in the air and it hits a baby in the
head and there's blood everywhere and
these same patterns are repeated over
and over again.
Hundreds of these videos,
maybe thousands.
A lot of them have been removed from
youtube.
Right?
They've been pretty proactive about
Clinton Tarantino making cartoons.
It's fucked up.
See if you can find them,
see what Eli Roth played on a founder,
weirder playlist of like this guy
dissecting candy and making weird voices
over it.
And then there was a whole list of
videos that people are saying like,
what the fuck is this channel?
What's going on here?
And it just got bigger and bigger and
bigger and I don't think anything's had.
It's just weird shit.
It's really different than youtube kids
thing.
No,
no,
I think he's done with the kid thing
though,
is more fucked up because it's always
the same pattern.
It's like these kids get together with
the parent,
the parents give the kids booze,
the kids get drunk,
they throw bottles,
that baby gets hit in the head with a
bottle.
There's blood everywhere.
It's like the same thing over and over
and over again.
There's been all these videos exposing
these videos like people that are
analyzing and saying,
what the fuck is this?
And it seems to be foreign.
They seem to be done in other countries
and essentially what they're doing is
they're tapping into this.
They have a like a pattern that they
use.
They're tapping into whatever algorithm
that creates your coming up next.
These adjusted.
Yes.
So a little kid can be watching like a
real donald duck cartoon and then it
leads into this.
Yeah.
I don't think that's what anyone's
really complaining about it.
I think we can all find common ground,
like let's get rid of the Minnie mouse
being raped on youtube,
but the problem is I understand her
perspective and that's what they told us
to almost a year ago,
but I even asked them,
I said,
hold on a second.
You just wind and Dynas and you showed
us your whole virtual reality set.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
What were the most advanced?
No,
that's what youtube wants to be at the
forefront of policy.
You know,
they're really aggressively under this
net neutrality thing.
Everything.
Google really big policy wonks.
Really big lobbyist if you look at them,
but they go so okay,
you're super advanced.
Most technologically advanced company in
the world,
but our channels is a real life one.
That's kind of the same,
same kind of shit,
but these aren't as offensive to me.
Is the cartoon ones.
Okay.
This gets.
We're always taking a 15 minute weird
video.
Just weird stuff happening.
Like kids are supposed to watch this.
They stumble across it because the
algorithm,
you know,
if they're watching tune with spiderman
in it,
this shows up next.
Oh,
does she get drunk and he raped her.
She's getting tied up a second ago.
That's a really shitty spiderman and I
wouldn't be fooled.
Yes.
That wouldn't make it past our wardrobe
anyway.
Alright.
But the point is you can't claim to the
most advanced tech company in the world.
And then in our channel you're,
you're,
you're getting ads for Muslim singles
and gay cruises,
like I'm on a second.
Your algorithm that's kind of figure out
it is pretty fun,
but we're not getting any money from
those ads.
Like you can't find.
That means that if our videos are
controversial,
right,
or videos or not a violation of
guidelines,
there are sponsors out there.
And when we see with Walter,
you know,
firearm company came to sponsor,
they seek us out because it's worth
octupled to them because they want to
reach our audience.
Whereas Youtube says,
well,
no,
it's not advertiser friendly.
No,
no.
It's not advertiser friendly for the
people you on there.
It's not gay cruise advertiser friendly.
But you're telling me you have the most
advanced algorithms in the world and
you're running ads for young Turks on my
video.
Like I really?
Yeah,
I think so.
A bunch of leftist ads and you might do
that on purpose.
I will be hysterical.
Impression when you,
when you went to that one conference and
you went as him,
he,
he just goes,
oh,
it's very disappointing.
I would have thought that was hilarious.
I mean,
first of all it was disappointing.
There was only 20 people in there.
I wouldn't even gone out and been like,
look,
let's take this to a smaller place
because if a video gets out of this,
this is fucking embarrassing.
Is 20 people in this one room and then
you walked in as him.
I didn't want to do it.
Like he had called me out and this,
we've had people even on this show,
of course you wanted to do it.
That's why,
you know,
he knows I didn't want to do it.
And I was like,
but I feel like I have to because he
called me out and I said I accept,
you know,
basically like okay,
let's.
And then he called you out.
How so he was talking trash.
I mean it oil,
community,
bullshit,
that whole thing.
So it's like,
okay.
I responded,
I'm like,
let's hash this out.
He will mention he will rebut every Tom,
Dick and Harry on Youtube,
not named Steven crowder.
So at this point I was just trying to
get an interview with him.
We used to,
we've had people on our show we disagree
with.
We do it an hour long.
Change my mind where I sit down and
listen to someone scream at me.
I'm more than willing to video.
You did the.
Were you drinking the bacon grease and
you did.
It was pretty him and funny.
Come on man.
It's fucking funny.
It made me laugh,
but the point is he forced my hand,
right?
I had to do it like he.
It's like that guy in diners to punch
all the people who ganged up on a
baseball diamond throughout the day.
I was like,
well no,
I have to do this with Cenk because
there's no other recourse.
And he kept going to the audience that
the only reason we show the audience
like youtube,
there's another recourse,
like you have to go to.
The Bain has to escalate.
He goes,
he goes,
listen to like you.
So it's like at this point you brought
up the audience.
Let's do a pan.
You know,
there's 20 people,
like I don't want to go up and embarrass
the guy,
but he's such,
just such an asshole.
You know,
there's just no way around it,
so we kind of retired.
That character to character is funny
when you're drinking the bacon grease.
That's not true.
We brought them back this week and I
know that's right.
I've had nothing but pleasant dealings
with Jank.
Nothing,
but I don't have any hate for the guy,
but I laughed because I run the
handshake with them.
It was a wonderful moment.
Was it?
Yeah,
it was great.
Good.
Yeah.
I just think like most people,
they get embroiled in conflict and then
they lose perspective and then it builds
up and then it becomes something stupid
and I think you know,
his thing with Alex Jones is handled
very poorly and they start screaming at
each other and Anna called him a fat
fuck.
God Damn.
You can't do that.
Just is against everything you guys
stand for.
You calling him a fat fuck.
You can't just shaved him.
Me.
Meanwhile jenks fatter.
This is fucking crazy.
Like,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
Which links put them on.
That's A.
I don't think he realizes that yet.
I don't think he's at the point where he
realizes that he's,
you know,
he's bigger than Alex.
Oh really?
I don't think he's lying to himself.
I know.
I don't want to speculate on how he
looks at herself in the mirror and what
he tells himself in the morning and get
to the deck.
He said my dealings with Janka had been
nothing but pleasant.
I like talking to him.
I had him on the podcast.
I like talking to them.
I just think people lose their place.
They lose their,
lose their,
their,
their view of the world.
Well,
I think when your identity is entirely
tied up in the numbers,
right?
When it's entirely tied up,
his only defense was looking at the
audience.
It's like,
hold on a second that,
that ebbs and flows.
I mean,
you know,
even,
I mean you guys obviously have a crazy
successful show,
but some shows are more popular than
others of course.
And for them they,
you know,
this far left sort of I guess
progressive viewpoint and they've gotten
increasingly worse is not popular.
And when that's your only argument,
when that's your whole identity is a
very short time between that and when
the pendulum swings and that even,
even the,
uh,
we need debate it.
Ben,
Ben Shapiro.
Yeah.
That was the audience the year before
was him and Dinesh D'souza.
You're welcome.
And people were clapping for them.
And then when he was sitting there with
Ben,
it didn't work.
Well,
the Da Dinesh one,
he had that ace in the hole.
Like that card,
like you went to prison as a fucking
tough card to get by.
It's pretty funny.
It is funny.
It's funny to picture the national
prison I'm friends with,
you know.
Well I felt like the Sam Harris one was
a big downfall for him.
Ben Affleck and all that stuff.
Sam just handled it better.
You know,
when they were in,
they had that long three hour
conversation in a three hour
conversation with someone.
You know,
it's hard to hide.
It's like your ideas get exposed,
your lack of knowledge gets exposed.
Well that's what the left doesn't do it.
And I know people say,
well,
okay,
if we do a segment where the biggest
success for us this year that we're
really grateful for is that changed my
mindset and that's just where I
literally sit down and we put up a booth
that says I'm pro gun changed my mind,
or I'm prolife changed my mind,
or there are only two genders.
I'm pro gun change,
wildly unpopular here and go in the
wrong spots.
I can tell you where to go.
And uh,
we had one that was like an hour long
thing on abortion.
One that wasn't just at Smu,
five people just lined up and I just
listened to them.
And out of the five people,
two of them changed their mind.
And then some of them we didn't find
com.
It's completely unedited.
And everyone,
when I worked at Fox News,
everyone in cable news would have told
you this would not work and no one's
going to watch an hour long discussion.
But there's no one on the left who does
that?
Well,
they can't do it in their format.
They can't do it when they have an eight
to 10 slot or an eight to nine slot and
there's every 15 minutes you have to
champ sandwich and a commercial and then
you have all these segments that you
have to play.
They can't do it,
but that's just because their format
sucks.
Like it's an art.
It's an antiquated form of
entertainment.
It just doesn't work anymore.
But even the lifts on Youtube,
like the young Turks,
they don't do that.
The unedited is long form thing because
it shows are there on,
on Youtube.
What are they like really popular ones?
I don't know.
They're really Sam Cedar Show,
right?
The majority report is.
He used to fuck that up.
I called the minority report once.
That's easy to easy to do.
Yeah.
They think I did it on purpose or were
they mad?
They thought you were doing like the
conservative talk show thing where
you're like,
Nah,
that
Democrats don't do that.
I think they also call me right wing
too,
which was like,
all right,
let's see.
Did you pick up the.
One of the things they were saying was
that people just decide that these
people that we decide to help each other
out,
that the right supports themselves and
they support like other right wing
people,
but the left needs to figure out how to
do that.
I'm like,
I'll fucking have anybody on.
Yeah,
I have a left wing people on all the
time.
I have libertarians and all this.
I have people that are completely
neutral to politics on all the time.
I just think when you box yourself into
these ideologies when you're only pro
left and you can't see any perspective
outside of that,
it becomes an issue,
which is it's going to be an issue for
you today.
After a double feature of Jordan
Peterson and us,
they're probably going to come fast.
Fuck,
I really don't.
I mean,
Jordan Peterson Hall knew it when I was.
When I was doing this.
First of all,
Jordan Peterson,
you know,
I'll have that guy on anytime.
He's one of my favorite people to talk
to it.
Just a fascinating guy,
but I knew like having to back to back,
I was like,
oh,
it's so fucking old road zone,
which is just embracing it.
What are the notes,
you know,
but you're definitely on the characters
that appear in the past.
It's of all the variables.
What I wanted to talk to you guys about
is some of my favorite stuff that you've
done and some of my favorite stuff
you've done is the undercover shit and
one of the things that I've found the
most disturbing was when youtube posed
as a gay couple and you went to that
place where they were advocating
transgender children and transitioning
children as young as three years old.
Right?
Was.
I was three years old,
but puberty blockers.
Yeah.
They were talking about.
Yeah,
but I think it was really fucking.
Yeah.
Oh No,
no.
You know what?
Actually three years old was Owen.
Benjamin got in an argument on twitter
and lost his manager because he was
saying that someone is fucking insane.
Forgiving puberty blockers to a three
year old kid for giving hormone blockers
to a baby,
which I am.
Fuck yeah.
That's not even a strong enough word.
I mean,
it's insanity.
Fucking insanity.
Meet your bodies aren't even developed.
You're not even close.
We're not talking about 18.
We're not even talking about 21,
which is arguable.
Still crazy.
Like you really try waiting to your
fucking frontal cortex is fully
developed and figure out who you are.
But the idea that you're gonna know at
three,
who are you going to be when you're 30?
Well,
they present the other side.
Banana.
They act as though you're crazy.
That was it.
They were like,
well,
you know,
the thing is with the puberty.
Remember that person looked like me with
a look like from Hook.
Well let's play.
Let's play some of it because it's.
It's fucking nuts.
When I watched it,
I was like,
oh my God.
Like what are these people saying and
have been taken down since you asked me
about that to really?
Yeah.
We have to set the blurt the guy.
Well,
I'm not afraid who tickets.direct spot.
Dr Rex,
but who shows up and prizes name my name
is rigged,
but that his kid you not,
I kid you not.
We had a business card.
Real world.
We're in a goddamn simulation.
This was a town hall.
We're in a simulation.
This can't be real.
A Guy,
his name is rex,
but.
And he got,
you know,
Youtube.
Okay,
let's play some of this and
if there's a way for most of the people
are listening rather than watching.
So you already know what's.
You gave him the.
No,
let's set this up.
Intern.
So what was this?
Okay,
it was.
We'll knock a jared and here's one.
Let me,
can I preface this with something again?
We don't like.
We're not undercover journalists.
We do a late night show.
That's what we do.
We do coffee to the Mandala.
Would you joke sketches and we do
interviews and then every now and then
we stumble across something.
And when you're doing,
for example,
like Antifa and they hand you a knife
and they talk about shooting that too.
But the point is,
and then when the media just lies about
it,
like we feel compelled to.
This isn't our thing.
This is one.
This particular one was kind of a
throwaway.
It was a throne.
We were joking.
It was a goof.
It wasn't even bothered with costumes.
If you just walked in separate queer,
it was what?
The health care.
Transgender town hall where it's like,
oh my transgender town hall.
Transgender.
Where was it at?
Vermont.
Burlington,
Oh,
that place is crazy.
I wasn't a plane with Bernie Sanders on
the way there to wow money.
I'm going to give it to the blacks.
Okay.
Right.
Let's,
let's play.
Has said
that feels like a girl playing with
dolls.
And of course we don't want to
discourage it.
Um,
we spoke with our primary care
physician.
He said,
wait until the boys fully developed.
We made his own little thing.
That's me.
I would say a little inaccurate from the
research I've done.
The kid,
18th,
two lists.
It was just like,
okay,
get rid of the pope.
Puberty blockers.
They just go through late puberty.
Say anything still lined up.
There's no indication that there's any.
Damn.
That's not true at all.
Puberty blockers are not reversible.
That's the entire point.
That's not the point.
The young adult,
someone at the pre adolescent age going
into those Adelaide.
It's going to change the way your body
to Bella
at.
Yeah,
I mean there's no way.
Giving a kid a puberty blocker,
letting them go through life with a
puberty blocker and then at 17 or
whatever the fuck it is decided to take
that shit off.
You're going to be the exact same human
being.
You would have been with the same people
worried about little estrogen and milk
cartons.
So then this guy say free plastic,
because I don't want it to alter my
hormones by.
I'm gonna chop off my balls and do
puberty blockers at eight,
but this is.
I mean,
you can't let a kid make those
decisions.
You can't make those decisions for a
kid.
They're too young to.
You.
Remember he had a winner five minutes
ago.
I thinking about these things.
No,
no,
he's fine.
He knows his bugger off on the couch
three minutes ago and now you're letting
them decide.
Is Hormonal profile the idea that a
child who's six years old or whatever
would know the consequences,
but them saying that 18 is too late and
that it's not that they would disagree
with your primary care physician,
that it's too young based on the
research that I've done.
What fucking research have you done?
What you.
You can clearly point that a good idea
to
transition a six year old.
Well,
that's a problem.
Here's another problem.
We don't know if youtube is going to ban
this video because of what you just said
to you.
This video is going to get marked for
demonetization.
Well,
yeah.
The d,
the Jordan Peterson one just got flagged
and we talked about this book.
We talked about the 12 rules for life
and talked about a guidelines for living
a hell.
Just started reading it.
That's great book.
Let's keep going.
Officers play
more or less to understand themselves
and the task reads a particular length
and the diameter and the penis is
developed enough.
Then there'll be enough.
If,
if.
If you're going to try,
you're going to transition to either
way.
Oh,
because that's the problem.
I was like,
you know,
jazzy and no material of creative
vagina.
If the testicles and the peanuts are
developed enough,
did you know this?
Did you know that unless your penis gets
big enough,
you can't get a fake vagina cause
there's not enough tissue to invert.
So he's like,
this is him.
He's like,
now if you decide to transition the
other way,
meaning if you decide to not transition
iep murder,
how everyone made fun of this,
the beauty pageant girl when she was
asked about gay marriage and gay
marriage or opposite marriage and
everyone laughed and it was silly.
You know what I mean?
She was conservative.
It was silly,
but he's doing that right here.
Like should you choose to transition or
transition the other way?
You mean should you choose to not cut
off your penis?
That's transition the other way.
Now,
not only that,
there's a lot of people in the
transgender community think it's
offensive to assume that you have to get
an operation,
get your penis removed in order to be
transgender or Muslim.
This guy's making this big assumption
that this is what you have to do in
order to transition.
I know a lot of people that are
transgender that do not have the
operation.
I don't know a lot of people.
Let's just say I'm in a community focus
group with transgender people.
By the way too.
I'm 100 percent in favor of grown adults
deciding to transition.
I know.
I think you should be able to tattoo
your face.
Get nose rings.
I don't give a fuck what you do.
I really don't.
But you're also asking the government to
pay for your face tattoos.
Yes.
That's true.
Well,
and there was another thing.
I'm here.
I'll send this to Jamie.
That was some research today that,
uh,
someone put out here.
I'll play this and I'll forward this to
Jamie.
I'll text this to keep playing.
That's it.
That's that clip.
I don't know,
but yeah,
I mean that was.
The thing is,
that's a good example.
It's a public town hall which we attend
and it gets removed from youtube because
someone who handed us as business card
rex.
But this is serious by the way,
like we did the rest of us.
We weren't nearly as mad about this as
we were just just,
just in,
in doubled over in laughter.
The guy's name,
he had trouble getting less secure in
the url,
writes his own initiative to her website
url.
I just sent this to you,
Jamie,
if you follow the tweet,
it is a by Dr Deborah.
So,
and uh,
it is um,
uh,
an article from the National Institute
of Health Study,
Dr. Zero van meter pediatric.
Oh,
okay.
Oh No.
Tuesday is your chronologists.
Well,
she's anti Aldis.
They don't give any leeway to Asians.
I get the minority group that they
actually get more crap.
It's like,
well,
you're up.
You have to be better than everyone to
get into a good college because have two
minutes to just so many really good
ones.
Yeah.
Okay.
Dr q van meter,
a pediatric endocrinologist with
extensive experience in gender
dysphoria,
which by the way is hate speech.
Says there is zero point zero evidence
that the concepts of gender fluidity and
gender identity have any scientific
basis.
Yeah.
So,
um,
this is why should include zero point
zero zero.
That's the second zero.
She's money thinking about cash doesn't
mean anything.
Just thinking about cash money.
Well,
I guess you could have zero point zero.
One percent.
You could have 100.
She wanted to make sure there's no
doubt.
Yeah,
she started in those extra characters.
We just got brown.
She's very,
the extra 2:40 characters.
I'm of those that you say like hate
speech.
Gender dysphoria is still in the DSM
five.
What does that,
the actual,
like the psychiatric journal that they
use a reference book.
But they literally call it hate speech
now.
Yeah,
I know,
but it's the actual medical condition.
What's crazy in that?
Undercover.
God bless my wife.
She went with us because we need other
people to have hidden cameras.
And so she posed as a lesbian movie kind
of lesbian,
you're like,
really?
You Exist?
And like the full,
they couldn't say anything.
Well she remember said like I identify
as someone with bigger breasts and she
was asking how to get this covered under
Medicare,
medicaid because they were talking about
getting all these operations and Mr
Rick,
God bless them,
but I think we should mention that,
you know,
talk about that gender dysphoria.
So for her they use gender dysphoria to
try and file it medically to get new
tits on taxpayer dime,
but it's considered hate speech to say
it to the tree,
the transgenders in the room.
It's just crazy.
Like you can't make sense of it and I
don't need to make sense of it.
I just need to not be banned for just
wanting to be the woman she was meant to
be.
Right.
Well,
I mean,
anything that you can mark is bullshit.
I mean if you could mock it that openly,
if that's not obvious,
like getting,
getting bigger tits because you identify
as someone with bigger tits.
I mean that's bullshit.
That's why it's so funny.
I don't think I've ever been in love
with my wife that when she did that
shit,
I wouldn't expect that she's looking at
me.
She kind of nodded to someone who has
bigger breasts.
Well,
did you see that guy that got busted
molesting children and said he
identifies as being a 60 year old boy?
That was a really recent case.
I mean,
people are trying this out when they get
caught doing things and I'm not saying
that there's not people out there that
identify with being a man when they're
actually a woman or vice versa.
That's not what I'm saying,
but what I'm saying is there's a lot of
fucking crazy people out there a lot and
to deny that and just because it's
dealing with gender.
You're,
you're in.
We're in Narnia now.
We're in la La land here.
When you're,
you're,
you're not being real.
No.
Well,
let me,
let me ask you this,
because like you said,
you're not right wing.
I'm pretty open about the fact that I'm
right wing.
I remember watching a show a while back
and you had a little little guy,
little guy killed a buck.
Buck and angel.
Yeah.
I'm a little guy that used to be a gal.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then,
I don't know what I said,
but
at the same kind of conversation we have
here,
like I don't just go and look at the
school,
you,
you're training.
I said,
well I don't know.
I just don't buy it.
And he,
he,
he wanted to get into a fight with me.
You wanted to have a fight.
Let's fight it out of this.
This was years ago when you got a fresh
shot of test jacked,
but you know,
like huge at one time.
Oh was he?
Oh yeah,
it got up to like 185,
like super jacked because just banging
test in there and fucking lifting.
But he was saying that his joints hurt
really bad when he was doing that.
It's almost like it's unnatural.
So crazy.
But back then when you get them on
jacked jacked.
I had a role with that guy and be like,
fuck it.
Go.
No,
come on.
You wouldn't have come on that to be
kind.
Yes,
yes,
exactly what the point is back then.
Let me ask this.
Did you realize it was gonna get as
insane or did he just think this is an
interesting guest?
Well,
he's a nice guy and you know,
I,
I'm more than willing to call them a man
and that was one of the things that I
said.
I said,
look man,
you're a person who would whatever your
name is,
buck or fred or Wilma,
I don't care.
Whatever you want to be called,
I'll call you whatever noise that you
connect with you as a being,
I'm fine with that.
And if you can explain to me where you
feel happier being a man.
I'm 100 percent in support.
Are you doing that?
What drives me crazy is people making
decisions for six year olds,
people pushing six year olds in certain
directions and I know that this does
happen.
I know and I,
I,
I just can't get too personal about
this,
but I have a friend who has an ex wife
that turned his child into a girl.
Yeah.
And,
and like tried this and was,
was pushing this and kids are very
fucking pliable man.
Oh yeah.
This is not.
I mean,
maybe some boys would've rejected it and
maybe he was leaning that way anyway,
but she was excited about it and this
is.
This is something that a lot of people
are excited.
I mean,
we're talking about a 14 year old.
I just don't think you know who the fuck
you are.
You know?
What is that girl's name?
Ruby rose.
Is that her name?
The attractive lesbian with the tattoos.
She said that when she was young she
wanted to transition and she's very
happy that she didn't.
She wanted to become a man and she's
very happy that she didn't and she's a
lesbian and she's happy and she's open
and super successful,
but she's advocating the sort of the
same thing that I'm saying.
It's like let people become a God damn
adult and then make these in in
alterable life changing decisions.
This guy saying that hormone blockers
can be turned off and then you could go
through a normal puberty.
You're out of your fucking mind and I'm
not a doctor,
but I have enough understanding of
biology to know that.
That's crazy.
That's just not true.
No,
it's absolutely not true and that's one
of those things you listen to.
Anyone can get lost in the weeds and
make someone look stupid.
Something specific,
you know,
whether it's.
I mean you were showing me that compound
out there.
It's fascinating.
I don't know anything about it.
I'm going to be a moron,
you know,
less than room temperature Iq.
Some doctor can come in who's pro
transgender and explain something and
make it sound like we don't know what
we're talking about.
So when it comes to that,
I don't,
I don't agree with
you there.
Well I don't agree with you on their
terms.
We wouldn't know.
It doesn't matter.
What terms are there that you don't know
about a child's biological development?
Well they,
what they point to the.
Actually there are these studies that
show that the,
you know,
the brain alterations occur before,
across hormone replacement therapy and
it's actually,
it's not true.
So we have a few transgender people on
our show,
but the point is with these,
whether it's a conspiracy or,
or you say,
okay,
I'm not a doctor,
but I can't just appeal to authority.
I can't just say this doctor says x,
so I do have to at this point,
accepting that I'm not a doctor except
the preponderance of evidence from the
overall medical community and combine
that with the anecdotal and combined
that with,
is there a motive here?
Is there an agenda here,
like a lot of conspiracy theories and
just doesn't add up because who benefits
from telling you,
you know,
the world is flat.
Who benefits from it?
Now I can understand how someone might
benefit from a conspiracy was like,
oh,
they make a lot of money off of this.
Or was it Tim Kennedy as a hunting
Hitler thing?
I'm not saying it,
but it's like,
okay,
I understand after war,
uh,
they thought maybe they had Hitler and
they needed the healing for the country.
Okay,
I can understand that.
But with this,
there's,
it just doesn't add up as to none of the
arguments.
They present that up from millennial
parents to whack off turning the age of
their children to social experiments.
It's disgusting.
That was Owen Benjamin's take Benjamin's
take was that this guy in Hollywood,
I don't remember who it is,
who's talking about transitioning his
three year old and he was like,
you're a fucking monster.
And he was getting in trouble for this.
He lost his manager show because he
writes for our show now we bring them in
on skype and we just sit and we kind of
brainstorm.
And uh,
he wasn't really out of the closet.
I remember at that point and I said,
oh,
and I don't think you want this because
I had lost my manager.
And my agent was like,
I don't think you want this kind of
heat.
And the conservative,
the conservative and the industry,
it's a real thing that's hilarious.
Like,
yeah man,
I think it's going to.
I'm like,
I don't think you want this kind of
heat.
And he talked about it on our show first
and it was almost like he was spit
balling because.
Because then he tweeted something that
was really funny from the show and then
this just all hell broke loose.
And I was like,
I told you that's what was going to
happen.
And so now he's just full boar because
you can't,
you can't put that back in the bottle.
And that's the crazy thing.
Like Owen was the quintessential
nonpolitical,
just sort of happy go lucky comedian.
It's totally changed.
And now if you see as act this,
and I know one kind of did that on this
show.
Yeah,
I mean that's one of the things that
happen.
Like on this show,
we were just talking about all the
various things and also he was talking
about his dad being flamboyant and his
mom being kind of masculine and he grew
up in this weird environment and you
know,
he's just,
he's a great guy.
I mean he's just,
this is his take on things,
you know?
And He loves to talk shit on twitter.
He loves to stir things up and he does
it too much.
I told him,
I told him the exact you.
I was like,
oh,
and just take it down.
Not Love you own.
Yeah,
I've,
I send them a text the other day.
I'm like,
you go,
first of all,
while your techs coming to me green,
I go to just flip to us.
Yeah.
He got rid of the ego.
You addicted to your phone.
He goes,
yes.
I go,
dude,
like you're fucking crazy.
Like,
which is great.
Which most comedians in some
way crazy,
but I'm like,
you know,
just you're tweeting too much.
It's like,
you're right.
I got to walk away from it.
To me,
this whole thing about your transgender
ism or something,
it'll be tweeted out,
I guess reality from the left and
progress and then I'll respond and then
I don't hear anything back and be like,
oh sorry.
I was out chopping trees.
His brother's an arborist and he helps
his brother.
It means literally
fucking 20 feet up with the ropes and
shit.
He shifted me Maple Syrup for Christmas.
I believe we're is a great guy.
The promise with Owen and when we get
into the same room,
jared,
someone else has to manage us because
I love him and I,
I just hate that happened to them too.
We were,
you want to have that conversation it.
I just feel that he needs to do is do a
podcast and get his,
you know,
just get his stuff out there more and
he'll find his own audience.
He doesn't need all this other shit.
You know,
there's a,
there's an illusion in Hollywood that
you need to be cast and things you need
to be cast a bowl and this castable
thing,
and I've said this,
one of the reasons why I have no actor
friends is because I have a couple that
I'm friendly with,
but as my inner circle of people I hang
around with on a regular basis.
Comics and fighters,
just people that I deal in reality.
The actors are always trying to get cast
in things and there's a dynamic that
occurs when you're always trying to get
cast in things where you never want to
say anything that's controversial.
You don't want to have any opinions that
don't fit into the standard acceptable,
digestible Hollywood dogma,
whatever it is.
And it's always left wing.
Like what happened with Tim Allen?
He came out as right wing and they
canceled his fucking shit.
Like,
fuck you and fuck your show.
He was a John case at guy do.
You don't have to be outright.
John Casick.
Yeah.
As big of a pussy as as the Republican
Party as a moderate Republican,
but still right wing enough where
they're like,
fuck you to wiener saying you just like
to touch a little boy.
It's like it just ruins your career.
It's disappointing and you would fix it.
Maybe you'd like a video of that.
It shows up on your feet.
What are you talking about?
House of cards.
Kevin Spacey was never crazy.
Awesome.
So he's a different animal.
That's a different animal.
I guess I didn't.
I never met him,
but I guess that has been saying about
him for ever.
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
This is like what Milo talked about.
Okay.
And this is.
This is all very taboo stuff,
but in the gay community it's far more
acceptable for a man to be dating a 15,
16,
17 year old boy that's openly gay,
right.
Than it is in the straight community.
If the straight community have you find
out that a 40 year old man is dating a
14 year old girl,
that guy is,
that guy's a piece of shit and he should
be locked in a fucking cage,
but if you find out that in the gay
community it's,
it's,
it's different strokes for different
smells.
I mean I can name you several people and
we worked in Canadian TV particular like
makeup artists who were like,
no,
the capable.
Michelle likes them young.
It was a common thing.
I am not at all saying that it's
acceptable.
No,
Kevin Spacey,
but what I am saying is what bothers me
the same with the me too campaign like
Meryl Streep coming out,
everyone coming up with the Harvey
Weinstein,
the germ right.
We all a piece of crap,
get it.
We all know that,
but not one person.
Okay.
They all Kinda like,
yeah.
He tried to do that with me too.
Not One person came out and said,
yeah,
I got three Oscars.
I did it,
bitch.
No one.
No one admitted.
No one just like no one else is saying.
Yeah,
you know,
it's well known secret.
This happens a lot in Hollywood.
There are a lot of guys with young 15
year old boys.
It's super common.
You go to the,
you go to the right bar.
Evangelists.
Well the Bryan singer thing,
right?
Right.
Bryan singer,
there's photos of his party.
There's a pool filled with boys like
literally,
and what's fucked up about is there's
red lights in the pool and we had a
field day with it.
You could,
you could imagine where we imagined the
blood came from,
but there's literally a red pool filled
with young hairless boys.
They weren't hiding it.
No.
That's the thing.
They didn't have to know.
Fully accepted.
That's why the fake outrage bothers me.
I'm not.
It's a fake outrage,
I think.
Yes,
from the left and Hollywood,
not America.
America is outraged that Kevin Spacey
Shipping Fourteen Year Old Boys.
Well,
I think it wasn't just that.
I think what really got Kevin in trouble
was not just the initial story,
but then that he was grabbing dicks on
the set and he was just.
He would get,
there's the,
there's the red pool.
I mean,
come on son.
Oh Geez.
I mean if that was a bunch of gals and
you were just excellent,
that'd be a boldly painting video for
Youtube.
This is all wolverines.
Next victim.
Let's see what you guys look like.
It was the casting party for the first
class,
but um,
what Milo was saying when he was on the
podcast,
which ultimately got him in a lot of
trouble and lost his.
And then also he's saying it on that
other podcast that he did with the,
uh,
the amazing atheist.
I forget what,
what do they call their podcast?
You know,
the podcast.
I just know he got in trouble.
It's scoundrels or something,
something,
something like that.
Jamie will find him when he comes back
from the.
He's going,
he just bolted to the bathroom.
But what he was saying essentially was
that when you're a young boy and you're
gay,
you can have a very positive
relationship with an older man who acts
as a mentor and that was extremely
controversial and then ultimately cost
him.
And he was also saying that he had that
done to him on my podcast.
That's what he said,
that he was young.
He was molested,
but he said,
he goes,
please.
He goes,
I was a predator,
believe me.
I was the predatory.
Well,
hey,
you know,
what is the difference if someone
doesn't understand it,
they don't know where that line is.
What I mean,
like,
you know,
that if you were,
if you try working that out in the club,
and I believe me,
I was a Predator of the crowd,
is gonna go from laughing to uh,
what you have.
Oh,
that's the line.
Nice.
Caleb back.
But he's 14,
right?
If you're 14 and you're saying that you
were the Predator and you're the guy on
stage,
you're not,
you're not the man who's talking about a
14 year old boy that you want to fuck.
You're talking about you being 14 and
loving the fact that a priest molested
you and that you went after him.
I was a,
you know,
when
he,
when he was saying that it was down to
the.
It's very off putting.
She's beautiful.
She's wise.
She's an amazing smile.
What what he does is a lot of it is
stick and like it's sort of like a Gonzo
journalism type thing,
right?
Like you don't know when.
Where's the stick,
where's your real feelings on these
things,
and then where is the distinction
between how some heterosexual people
look at this and some gay people look at
this because I think that the spectrum
is different.
Like the spectrum of heterosexual people
to think it's acceptable for ground man
to have sex with a 14 year old is a
fucking very small,
like insanely small backwoods.
You know,
there's no straight nambla with
political clout.
Exactly.
You know,
there's no,
no one has a nambla bumper sticker,
but for isn't real anymore is it stays
real thing.
Fuck.
Someone tried to say,
uh,
I was a member of nambla one point in
youtube and suggested feet and I was
like,
okay,
all right.
I don't think that one's going to stick
something in,
scale it back now it is.
Now they're going to remember let told
thing we got to him.
That was the one
who does that,
don't you know?
That's j Hova.
That's cheesy.
Yeah.
Illuminati.
We meet on Tuesdays.
Oh,
Illuminati.
I always forget every now and he's.
He's an Illuminati.
I heard.
Yeah.
Ireland let them in every Tuesday.
Elon musk meet somebody else to show up.
Secret.
Yeah.
It is a.
here's one thing I will say,
so like,
this is why.
This is why people say you're right
wing.
Okay.
Mrs. I'm not saying you are so.
Let me preface it by the reason they
are.
No.
There is no leftist show after you said
which left the shows.
They're not having this discussion.
It doesn't exist.
If it doesn't,
there is the wild progressive left and
the people who get in line there is not
enough of a contingency today.
Put it this way,
James Demore a let go for what he wrote
on Google.
Not a single person we asked at the
Youtube conference had ever owned a gun
or knew someone who owned a gun.
Youtube,
Google,
facebook,
NBC,
ABC,
CNN,
CBS,
all of them.
None of them are standing up and having
this conversation saying even the highly
controversial issue of puberty blockers
with with which most people disagree,
they just go puberty blockers,
a new topic of discussion.
They go,
the left cannot not have this
conversation because you have to draw
the line before puberty blockers.
You have to draw the line at how far do
we have to play along with your
delusion.
It doesn't mean I don't like buck angel
doesn't mean we don't have Blair white
and our Youtube Carol video and are very
nice with her.
Was very against sexual puberty
blockers.
Yeah,
very against them and also on on
transformed and the nether regions.
Blair white.
Yeah.
See,
that's what we were.
We were wanting to ask
her boyfriend discussed this.
Super cool dude,
by the way.
Seems like a nice guy.
Seems like Nice,
but you're always asking.
You're asking questions.
You're not allowed to.
You ask questions,
but as soon as they leave,
as soon as they leave the room,
you're like that.
Well,
why can't you just ask,
what the fuck,
man,
I mean open as possible.
You're saying you used to be a man and
now you're a woman.
He gets on the table now,
baby.
What?
What could possibly be offensive after
that are more interesting?
We're talking about that.
Well,
the reason is because my,
my,
my mom who did wardrobe for the just for
laughs,
a lot of Kagan,
Sitcom,
so she just wardrobe for us now as we've
grown into these sketches and so Blair
white was the ghost of Christmas past
and this parody that we did and so my
mom had to go in and do wardrobe and
fitting.
So she had some questions.
First question comes back to me.
She's like,
no,
I think she had the.
I don't think she has that anymore.
I'm like,
well why she?
Because she said,
you know,
I did all this work.
I'm like,
but mom,
that could just mean,
you know,
she clearly has breasts and lips,
just think.
No,
I don't.
I don't know,
but I know I don't know what the pants.
When we fit,
I need conversation.
That's another hilarious character you
do.
Is that socialist French guy?
Montreal?
Yeah.
You know,
Bernie's like,
we've had interviews with people.
Did you meet Bernie?
You said he's on the flight with you was
on a flight with me.
No.
Here take a selfie with them.
I put on my socialism's for figs shirt
in the bathroom.
Here's what's so funny about Bernie
Sanders.
Socialism for fakes.
Figs says figs because it got pan from
instagram if you know.
So as a little fake least from the Che
air thing.
Anyway,
you'll see it.
You'll see it if you go to the store.
Point is Bernie gets on a plane.
This is right after the debate with Ted
Cruz,
the healthcare debate.
We did not go well for him and uh,
he doesn't even have a briefcase.
So you know,
he's not doing work.
He's going from DC to Burlington,
Vermont and he is,
I swear to you,
I took a picture on the absolute last
row of economy plus plus where that
first glass curtain goes by.
Probably ask for that because you know,
he can claim it like I don't fly first
class like you,
you're worth $5,000,000.
You said there with 128 gigabyte ipad
pro,
I could see it because they had the new
beds bevel,
so I could say like saving all the money
to deal with his wife's lawsuit for
tanking that college in Vermont.
I know that college too.
Yeah.
That story is fucking crazy that it was
a wild purchasing scheme that that tank,
the college,
like they decided to expand the land and
buy and they.
They tanked the college because of that
picture,
that America.
But what the fuck are you doing?
You're overspending.
Like what do you mean?
Why do you sound surprised?
What we need to do was get a rich
people's was fight.
So I put on the shirt and they're like,
you have to take a picture.
At this point it was what?
I was like 1230 in the morning.
This.
I wasn't always that Burlington trinity
to them all and so I get off the plane
and Bernie gets off the plane first
priority plus plus plus,
but didn't get the free cocktail mine to
get off the plane first done after
firstclass firstclass,
then him,
he gets his second back.
No,
no,
no.
First Class and then he's economy plus
plus plus.
So first quarter since it first class,
first class and everything but name
only.
And you know,
he says that every debate on like my
opponent,
I don't sit in first class.
All Right Bernie.
So he gets out first and I walked behind
him and it was like a,
Oh gosh,
what's his name?
Brooks in Shawshank redemption.
He was so old and everyone's walking
down the street and he walks down this
one hallway by himself with his ipad pro
and I remember calling Jerry said,
I can't do it.
I said,
I can't get.
It's 1230 in the morning.
The guy looks like he's at death's door
and I didn't want to be that jerk a
corner and I just wanted to talk with
them.
I wasn't gonna Sandbag him,
but he looked so it was so sad.
Well,
his posture so awful.
His next sits in the middle of his
sternum.
Mr Burton.
Turtle.
It's crazy.
It's like,
man,
you got to sit up straight.
Like that's not healthy.
You got to be in pain all the time.
If your head is like that low,
we'll,
we'll go to do the blue economy.
You got to get that money.
That blocks.
They could pay for my physical therapy.
Lifetime income inequality.
That's all.
He has a few bugs.
We're here.
Yeah,
but it's.
What I liked about him was that what he
was,
he seemed like a uniting force with
white people and black people.
It seemed like he was,
was doing interviews with killer Mike
even though he's anti gun,
you know,
and Mike is Super Pro gun.
I'm like,
but I'm like,
I like the fact that people are
embracing this crazy old guy.
And then the stage,
the stage was like,
oh right.
So you mean he was the guiding force
because of
that was that was not the platform.
I mean they,
if they wanted to have a meeting,
they should have had a meeting.
You can't just jump up and mix it in the
White House office right now.
That'd be fine.
President,
president now,
I don't know.
I think the problem is,
you know,
even if you have people who were
economic socialist who were on board
with them,
we have a lot of people who were pro
Bernie who then changed because they
just said,
well then he went full sjw in the black
lives matter feminism and that's why I
say even if you find a leftish and
nobody believes that,
like you're saying when you're in these
town halls and they don't know that they
all agree,
it really is a monolith and like that's
what they say.
You're right wing.
Because the truth is you could be
considered right wing just like he could
just like,
I could just like Jordan Peterson could
just like my local,
just like mentioned and all of us have
wildly differing views.
If you were to check the box off with
Cenk,
Bernie Sanders,
Hillary Clinton who take your pick,
they will check the same boxes because
they have to and I think that's why
they're losing so much ground culture
and the boxes are shifting to,
so we're,
we're the right side is expanding all
the different boxes you could possibly
check.
The left is shrinking.
You have to get in line with these
things.
Well,
we need have a real center in this
country does not have a real center and
I think that drives people to the left
and to the right.
I think it's a big issue or there's.
There's just too much toxic tribal
thinking here.
I just think when you truth,
I really like that.
Something that to me is,
I don't care if you're left or right,
just don't lie to me and the left has
been able to lie to everyone because
they've controlled the information
delivery for a long time.
I know that sounds conspiratorial and
it's right.
It's like what we're talking about with
Tim Allen.
I mean that is right.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's what we're talking about with
actors,
so you talk to most actors when it comes
to anything political,
they're almost all left wing.
That doesn't even make sense.
Like how the.
Exactly.
Yeah,
there's definitely,
there are a few people like we've had,
you know,
like Gary sinise and the show.
We've had some bigger name actress where
they have screw you money,
it doesn't matter,
but he's just the nicest guy ever where
he didn't even talk about politics.
He just builds these smart homes for
veterans just because he's like a saint,
but there are other actors that we can't
even necessarily name who were like,
I'd really like to do the show,
but I can't yet when I get to this stage
of my career,
I'm sure you've probably heard from
those people too.
They're afraid.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I've had people like that that say I
want to go hunting.
And I'm like,
uh,
yeah,
well let's,
uh,
let's film it.
No,
no.
I'm like,
you don't want people to know that
that's how you get your food.
I mean,
you know,
97 percent of the country eats meat and
I'm like,
really?
Is that high on that high?
Like what is it?
You're paying for it,
right?
So you're paying for the murder,
you're cool with that,
but you're not cool with doing it
yourself.
Right?
He goes,
no,
I'm totally cool with that.
I just don't want anybody else to know
like,
okay,
well that's part of the problem because
people don't want anybody else to know.
That's why it becomes so scary and taboo
and very few people come out.
You know?
It's just,
it's,
it's a lot of the same thing because
it's like you not,
you're not willing to express your
authentic self will and that's the
university like we're going to be at
Virginia Tech.
Is it sixth a week from today,
a week from today,
and already people lined getting ready
on facebook to protest and they were
like,
you haven't even seen the show.
We don't even know what it is.
This is the first time we're going to
take the show on the road and broadcast
live.
I mean,
it's just a powder keg because no one's
allowed to think differently.
Picture collegiate campuses.
That's what the left.
That's their utopia.
Listen,
you brought us something that,
um,
I think,
uh,
change the way people look at social
justice warriors.
That lady that was in the audience in
Amherst was puff.
That was like a gift from the heavens.
That poor gal.
It was like somebody created the
caricature.
You assume her gender.
I did
confident I'm a pig,
but when she was screaming at you,
I'm like,
this is not real.
This is like,
but rex,
this is not x,
but it's even worse.
Shit,
this is not real.
This can't be real.
This woman's not really.
This is like a caricature.
This is a,
this is a Michael J.
Fox movie from the eighties.
Were you like this?
No Way.
That's a real person.
Well,
you remember how stressed I was about
that because here's the deal.
Like this is my first time I was there.
It was Milo and Christina Hoff summers.
Now at this point,
I only remember you should use a mac or
a coca cola when you went to college
back when.
So that was my experience with colleges
and I hated it,
but for the first time I know now that
people are going to be protesting to a
significant degree,
um,
and I just wanted to go out and do their
degree.
I do some,
like I was telling him,
I'm like,
oh,
I don't know what I do here because like
they're just going to speak and lecture
and I want to do just,
you know,
a 20 minute set,
it's really tough because if,
I don't know,
if you don't acknowledge the Heckler,
if you don't acknowledge the person,
but then when you come out and it's just
ugly puff who doesn't have enough middle
fingers to give.
I've never given anyone that figure from
the stage.
I've never gone.
But I was like,
there's no.
I realized immediately I'm not gonna be
able to do stand
up.
And that was the ramp that went viral,
which I didn't expect it.
Like,
I'm just going to stay.
I'm just going to do my set and then
afterwards we'll do a q and a.
They wouldn't allow it and I just saw
her and I,
I just couldn't.
She looked like the abroad from Monsters
Inc at the front desk.
I was just laugh like she really did.
Yeah,
just show and everyone wants to.
Here's the thing,
you know,
I think it was my parents who maybe said
this to me when I was young and I got
cocky about something at one point and
they said,
don't ever Brag because it it,
it does.
It keeps us from being able to brag for
you.
Let someone else do it.
That's interesting.
Why?
It's a good way of putting it.
Same thing with strictly.
Did they say it with an accent?
We don't get to brag for you that she
had within this.
I don't know.
So,
so she had the work done.
We'll think about this if truly puff
didn't come out there and probably for
about eight seconds,
she took it out pretty quick.
She,
her dash didn't have the stamina,
needs carbs.
If she didn't do that,
we would always sit in.
You're talking about how if we just saw
our,
how we feel bad for her?
Yes.
Like,
Oh man,
that girl,
I hope she gets it,
you know,
and I feel it would be sympathetic,
but you prevent,
you preclude us from being empathetic
when you act like an absolute piece of
shit.
Your whole life threat.
Like all of a sudden we've shut off this
empathy for people because of the way
they behave.
We would all be like,
oh man,
poor girl.
I hope she finds a guy.
I'm sure she'll find a guy who likes
him,
you know,
bigger and you know,
she'll cheat and get it together.
And I've,
you know,
I've seen some people turn it around,
but when she does that,
you're just like,
oh,
I can't stand speed.
Boldest hiring.
See,
I thought it was so ridiculous that it
didn't.
I didn't even think that way.
I'm obviously I wasn't in the room while
she was screaming at me while I was on
the stage.
I probably would have been furious,
but sitting back watching it from the
comfort of my house,
watching it on Youtube,
I was like,
what the fuck happened?
That's poor kid.
Like I just like,
this is used to be someone you know as a
person who has a daughter,
so like this is someone's baby.
And then became this,
like someone didn't pay attention to
her.
They fed her bad food and,
and she's there by herself.
Like the whole thing was crazy.
Keep your hate speech off.
I can.
Meanwhile,
Christina Hoff summers by the way,
it couldn't be a nicer person and it was
so funny watching her with you and Milo
and she's like,
well,
I wouldn't say that.
I'm not necessarily saying that the
Islams stuff got.
She got uncomfortable because on there
she couldn't be a nicer lady.
I really love her.
She's really sweet.
We'll think about that.
Were on there.
She's basically kind of a lifelong
Democrats
branded right wing.
She's branded all right.
She is a super feminist,
but she calls herself the factual
feminist and her idea is that when you
distort reality,
when you start biology,
when you start facts,
you are doing your cause a disservice,
which is her cause.
Being an actual feminist.
She's a real feminist and she doesn't
think there's anything wrong with being
a woman.
She's like,
she doesn't think there's anything wrong
with wearing dresses,
putting on makeup and lipstick.
You're a woman,
you know,
probably two boxes.
She didn't check in the left column,
therefore.
Yeah.
Right.
And by the way,
she doesn't think there's anything wrong
with not doing that either.
She's very open minded but.
But she calls bullshit and because she
calls bullshit on that group,
she's shoved into this fucking Nazi
category,
which is so crazy to me.
Yeah.
And the danger with that is let's say 10
years down the line,
right,
you refer to me as not,
you refer to Joe Rogan is a Nazi,
not as a Nazi.
Christina Hoff summers.
You know what happens is when you refer
to someone as a Nazi for reasonable use
for just long enough,
they start saying,
okay,
you know what,
let's go with Nazi and people actually
go for the pendulum swings further the
other way.
That's what you're seeing with Europe
through.
You're seeing what this far right rise
because they're like,
you know,
like spend computer who works for us.
We brought them over from Germany.
You said,
you know there's,
there's a certain point for young people
don't want to go to every museum and go,
yeah,
we suck because it had nothing to do
with it.
He was in Germany,
you pay 65 percent income tax if you're
under the age of 30 school is free.
Think about that.
For a 65 percent it's 50,
but spend was telling us there's some
additional.
It's basically 65 percent and it's
entirely based on your age bracket.
You're under 30,
you pay 65 percent.
That's your effective tax rate.
So you have these,
a lot of money that hurts.
Yeah,
but that's what you see.
You see this far right?
Rising Europe,
because if you call someone a Nazi for
so long,
I'm like,
well,
wait a second.
I'm not a Nazi.
I just don't want Paris to become a
rape.
Then.
Yeah.
Well,
when you go from calling someone a Nazi
and then you see Charlottesville,
when you see guys with Nazi tattoos,
you go,
oh,
well that's not exactly.
This is a real Nazi.
This is a moron with a swastika tattooed
on his chest and a dodge challenger.
All this craziness left and right.
I just.
I'm just hoping it settles and what you
said.
Truth.
That's what I like.
I don't think that's where I always.
You know,
I know people.
People get upset.
I don't think truth is necessarily in
the middle.
I think truth is truth and sometimes
it's really far to the right and
sometimes it's in the middle.
I don't think that there's much truth in
today's progressive left now.
I think there's an ideological war going
on and I think especially with trump in
office,
they feel like the gloves are off and
all rules are out the window and
anything goes.
Yeah,
I think people are flabbergasted and.
Well,
I was telling Jamie before the show like
I'm,
I'm not without my criticisms for trump,
but I got to admit every time stuff just
rolls off his back like water on a duck.
I start fucking laughing like they were
like the stormy Daniels thing is going
to sink them.
I have a friend of mine who's who's gay
and he's the nicest guy in the world,
but he's so ridiculous.
He's like,
that's our Monica Lewinsky.
She's harmonically.
I go,
dude,
it's not going to work.
I go,
no one's going to care.
It's gonna.
It's gonna disappear in a couple of
weeks ago.
We're in a 10 hour new cycle.
Do you understand this?
I go in 10 hours,
some new shit comes along and nobody
gives a fuck about Brett ratner anymore
and nobody gives a fuck about this guy.
Nobody.
And there's a new guy and there's a new
thing and there's a new problem and
there's a new thing.
There's a new thing and you saying that
this porn star thing,
this is not 1994,
this porn star thing is not going to
sink him.
He's going to deny it.
Fake News,
fake nose and he's going to keep moving
and there's going to be nothing.
Yeah,
I don't even.
I don't even know what happened with
that exactly,
but to me I remember I just was like,
I got a disconnect for a bit because
I've been just going,
going,
going.
So I disconnected and like kind of
popped my head in for half a day
just because we're moving to a new
studio,
kind of like you've been doing and upon
my head it was like,
well,
what's the news?
What's this outrage right now?
Do I need to know about Donald Trump?
And they said,
no.
Yeah.
He called a Haiti a shit hole.
I just popped my head back.
I'm like,
of course it is.
That's it.
No one cares anymore.
Of course Haiti is that.
It doesn't mean you hate Haitians said,
why do these people from these shithole
countries want to come here?
That's what a supposedly said.
He says he didn't say it.
Some people say he did.
Other people say he didn't.
Who Cares?
So we're in a weird quagmire.
If he says he did,
he did.
Yeah.
It's not the appropriate thing for a
president of the United States to say,
but does it make sense that Donald Trump
would say that?
No,
no,
no.
You want to know how you know it's a
shit hole because French Canadian,
some of the most racist people you will
find love you mom,
but they create these French laws.
I've talked about this before.
Pure land.
It means pure wool because they want to
get rid of all the anglophone.
Right?
And so then they had a huge Asian
immigration because there's a lot of
French and people from Cameroon,
special diseases because of inbreeding
and they were furious.
So they try to create laws to keep the
Haitians out because they were.
It was just a clash of cultures.
Here's the thing,
Haiti is whether Donald trump,
senator not as a country,
a shitty place,
and I don't think anyone cares anymore.
She doesn't mean I hate Haitians,
doesn't mean I'm not empathetic to them,
but fortunate that they're in a bad
place,
but how is it racist if especially
you're criticizing a government which
comprises of black people who are
screwing a black citizenry.
They've been doing it for decades.
They've never gotten rain.
Wilson took a picture from sandals,
pickled pitcher from Club Med sandals.
Most people don't even know what that
is.
The resort.
That's so funny.
Yeah,
the Bahamas,
I think Jamaica,
one of those places.
No locale and all the other shit holes.
I mean,
I just like.
It's one of those things where I think
if nothing else,
Donald Trump has allowed people and we
weren't trump people.
We got so much flak from the outright
because we didn't support them.
I remember that.
And you were more in support of a Ted
Cruz,
right?
Oh,
I'll let Carly Fiorina and Ben Shapiro.
I mean Ben Carson a little bit,
right?
I just thought it was hysterical.
He's a smart guy,
so he's like,
it's so crazy.
Yeah,
he's like a Jim Henson care.
My favorite thing was him with Jesus.
The painting that Jesus on his shoulder
like,
whoa,
Ben,
neurosurgeon during an absolute genius
in that,
but you don't have the sense of like
maybe a little bit.
Well,
Jordan Peterson said something that's
very brilliant.
He said there is absolutely no
correlation with being smart and being
wise.
It's true.
There's a lot of people that are really
fucking smart things,
but they are not wise in terms of how
they behave and how they think and how
they conduct their life and whether or
not they pay for a Jesus painting their
shoulder.
It doesn't even look like Jesus.
It looks like a Puerto Rican
dude is slinging tacos.
It's a crazy painting.
It's so.
It's so bad.
I just knew this guy up here.
Yeah.
Nice.
Well,
everything's new.
We um,
used to have stars,
but the,
the panels were too
dark in this room because the lighting
is different here.
So we change them to clouds.
Got The American flag into that.
So people also think you're right wing.
Think about America or when do you ever
see a leftist?
Yeah.
When do you ever see the current
progressive leftist with patriotic
symbolism?
I usually have a American flag,
a case,
but I ordered one for the iphone x and I
didn't get it yet.
Look,
I love America.
I think America represents a beautiful
place of opportunity and it's not
perfect,
but I think it's the best place.
I've been to a lot of different places.
You know,
if you think there's something wrong
with being patriotic,
I think you're fucking crazy.
I don't think America represents the
worst aspects of us.
I think it represents possibility and
promise and that you have this ability
to do whatever the fuck you want to do.
There's not a class structure.
You can literally go from the bottom to
the top.
I mean you,
you,
you can do whatever the fuck you want to
do in this country.
There's some restrictions.
People say it's not a free country.
Hey man,
go to Canada.
It's a lot more fucking free than Canada
and Canada.
You can go to jail for not using
someone's preferred gender.
Pronouns is a case that just was out a
couple of days ago where some woman had
a sign and it was a it and they boiled
it down to like one word,
but her,
her sign said that I'm a transgender
woman is a man and you're just because
you feel something like that.
It does not overtake biology and
emphasis like long thing.
I'm just transgenders person wanted to
file a human rights violation case
against her and get her arrested and
said that the only way this person would
not would be willing to not do that was
b would be to sit down with this woman
and have coffee with her,
explained to her why she's wrong.
Well,
she doesn't think she's wrong,
so that's where you can't just decide
that this person has to act.
We ask.
They have to give into your particular
ideology and your line of thinking.
Otherwise it's hate speech.
That's not the answer like the answer
to.
If you think someone's wrong,
the answer is proving them wrong.
Having a conversation about it,
like some someone deciding that not only
is it wrong,
they're going to lock you up for it,
sue you.
That's crazy.
And I think especially with that Trudeau
guy up there like,
Ooh,
deepen,
remove a couple of bucks and you
could've just to run for office with
that speech.
It was very inspiring.
I could probably get up there and be,
if I could be a Canadian.
I'm a big fan of Canada.
I'm a big fan,
but they've got a few problems.
You know,
the first person ever voted for was
Stephen Harper.
Right?
So here's the deal back then.
Now I'm that guy.
I'm open about it.
Christian,
conservative,
everyone who harper.
Steven Harper was prime minister before
Trudeau.
So Stephen Harper is the Canadian
equivalent of a conservative,
so that would be like a little left to
have John Casick here in the states.
Here's there,
Megan.
They kind of heard that he was.
I mean we,
they didn't have the housing bubble
because they didn't do the subprime
loans.
Candidate was doing really well for the
first time was hiring the economic
freedom index in the United States.
I voted for him and everyone hated him.
Why?
Because he was a practicing Christian
conservative who believed in some form
of limited government.
Well,
now they have trudeau.
It's like,
I remember Steven Watson was a pastor
and I talked about this a lot and this
was a slippery slope thing.
It was a no,
no,
you're just,
you're just crazy religious nutbag.
This Guy Steven Wilson was a pastor who
I think was jailed.
He certainly was fine just because he
said,
I don't care what the laws of the land.
I'm not going to marry two men in my
congregation.
I'm not going to recognize that as
marriage.
That's what he said.
Whether you agree with them or not.
This was years ago,
and uh,
people in the left back then supporting
it because like,
well,
the only affects the,
the Christian pastor doesn't want to
marry dudes.
Beckon.
Well now it doesn't.
Now it affects the person who says,
if you're born a man,
you're a man.
And now it affects Mike Ward,
the comedian who was put before human
rights tribunal for making fun of the
make a wish kid foundation.
Yeah,
it does.
At a certain point you have to draw the
line and we want to decide that we're
going to draw the line when it comes to
like for example,
puberty blockers or do we draw the line
when someone tries to strangle Ben
Shapiro and the Dr drew show because he
implies that the guy with a penis is
still a man still.
There was.
That was rough.
That was a rough one because the guy was
literally threatening violence and it
was okay because Ben had ms dot
gendered.
Him and they cared have to have been
like,
well,
Ben,
to be fair,
you knew that was gonna not only touched
him,
putting his hands on him,
which is very threatening.
If someone's threatening me and they're
putting their hands on me.
I'm on def con nine.
I'm ready to go.
Like,
where's this going,
bitch?
Why are you holding onto me?
We fighting.
Yes,
you're,
you're holding me.
You're gripping me and holding me and
you're way bigger than me.
That guy was way girl.
Shit way bigger than Ben,
but ben's Ben was fucking strong.
That seems wildly inappropriate is one
of those guys
were sitting there like,
oh my gosh,
but yeah.
He said,
if you don't sound like the joker,
you're going to wind up.
If you don't speak,
you're going to want it.
You're gonna.
Go home in an ambulance.
It's like,
are you going to beat me up because I
say the wrong word.
Really?
Imagine.
That's what I'm saying.
You were a man.
He was like the clubber Lang of trainees
know.
That was one of the things that I got
into it with someone online about Fallon
Fox.
I said,
someone said she was always a woman.
I go,
okay,
but you know,
she got a man.
She.
She had a penis.
She used to be mad.
She got a woman pregnant and had a kid
with that woman.
I go,
was she a woman?
Then she goes,
even then I'm like,
we're done.
We're done.
We're in.
We're in Narnia.
Again,
documented that a woman is to youtube
because I didn't expect that.
I felt like I could say,
Hey,
I don't think it's cool if you get your
penis removed to beat the fuck out of
women.
I just felt like that's a safe thing to
start
going to be a contribution.
People like you're a bigot,
and I was like,
wow.
Well,
okay,
maybe you should at least tell them.
They used to be a man.
No,
it's a medical procedure and it has no
basis whatsoever on your physical
performance.
Well,
well that's not even structurally true.
That doesn't even make any sense.
The physical body's built differently,
you know?
Can you imagine if brock lesnar decided
to be a woman?
Just just imagine just not enough
hormone blockers in the world.
Keep that and then they didn't have to
tell anybody.
No.
It's a medical procedure.
They don't want you left.
Doesn't want you to tell people you have
aged so much.
I mean a penis as much.
That's the one you're on now,
Chad with not wonderful.
It used to be a felony and now it should
be.
Yes.
If you know you have a fatal disease and
you fuck someone in the but without a
condom,
that's where I'd read pool party.
That can't just be.
It can't just be transferred by playing.
Spin the bottle.
Did you ever see the guy who authored
that?
Yes.
The folsom street fair with the little
leather,
like a Bryan singer Pool Party.
It's hilarious.
It's hysterical that that guy pass that
through its people weren't paying
attention.
Like that's crazy.
Like I don't care if it's.
I don't care if it's aids or if you
could give someone cancer you,
if you have cancer and you know,
you have.
I mean if it was a communicable disease
and you decided to make out with someone
who doesn't have cancer and he gave it
to them like fuck man,
he just killed somebody.
You just smoked a pipe and kissed me and
now I have a soft skull cancer.
The bigger conversation on that too is
um,
like obviously it's not fatal anymore
because of protease inhibitors and all
this stuff,
but you just compared age to cancer was
once a day where you could just compare
aids to aids.
Well,
they used to Callie's the gay cancer,
you know,
that's when aids first came out.
They called it the gay cancer.
Oh,
we did.
We did a thing on that where we did a
defensive.
We did a show wishbone.
We did a parody with our dog hopper.
We did the AIDS epidemic and the AIDS
epidemic was always a hoax.
There was never an epidemic.
Basically if you were not doing heroin
with dirty needles or having unprotected
sex with George Michael,
you were pretty much safe.
People got so mad.
She knew it.
Yeah.
We just.
People knew what.
Do you remember the kinison bit?
Yeah,
I remember.
The kid isn't bit hysterical.
Yeah,
so we had a guy who came on.
It was actually very civil who disagreed
with by the end of it.
He just said,
well,
I guess it just disagreed because the
way you said it was so incendiary,
and I said,
hold on a second.
Why is it in Cindy or I am the one
actually trying to prevent people from
getting aids.
There are very specific patterns of
behavior that you avoid.
Don't have gang protected sex and a
truck stop.
Don't do heroin and the East village
like rent.
Where ever wanting to be rent.
Ever see that movie?
No,
because I'm straight.
I was crying at rent.
Oh,
and like every.
Every single person was doing heroin and
the East village and having unprotected
sex with each other.
If you make it past noon without getting
aids,
you're on borrowed time.
Like how am I?
I don't feel bad for you at this point,
but we had people,
they give us so much flack over the aids
epidemic and none of them disagreed with
the statistics.
You're just not supposed to say it.
Think about that for a second though.
The issue with that folsom street fair,
a senator or congressman,
you know,
I'm the guy with the beautiful leather
vest.
No shirt on underneath it.
Wander through the streets with a tire
around his neck that looks suspiciously
like a leash.
It was a hot topic discount.
I know Donald Trump had got
on sale at the hello kitty backpack.
So his argument,
I remember it was,
well,
this,
these laws,
only these disclosure laws,
and by the way,
for people who don't know what means,
you have to disclose that you have aids
if you're having sex with somebody.
Right?
These was only served to stigmatize
people.
Hold on a second.
Does it mean that we cannot stigmatize
anyone or anything ever?
We cannot stigmatize Abe's,
right?
Like it doesn't mean we hate you,
but we consciously delivering it into
someone.
I mean that's,
that's the problem.
Like being aware.
At what point are we okay?
Stigmatized,
right?
I mean what does it take to say like,
well you know what,
okay,
maybe we should stigmatize.
If I were to use an absurd example in a
bit,
we'll be like,
okay,
maybe we should stigmatize knowingly
transferring aids to somebody through
unprotected sex as a goof.
But instead like how we don't want to
stigmatize.
You're not even supposed to say aids,
right?
Because it's HIV and then HIV gives a
aids,
you know,
you get aids because your immune system
is compromised.
What aids is a syndrome acquired immune
deficiency syndrome.
I never got more hate in all the years I
did this podcast.
Then one of the early,
early,
early episodes.
What was that doctor's name?
The doctor from the University of
California,
Berkeley.
He is ostracized from the medical
community,
but he's a Duisburg.
Yes,
Dr Peter Duesberg.
He wrote an article in Spin magazine
way,
way back in the day and his assertion
was that
HIV is a very weak virus and that HIV is
appearing in the systems of these people
because they have compromised immune
systems.
It's not aids,
it's not HIV that's giving these people
compromised immune systems.
They already have compromised immune
systems and he was saying the reason why
they're having these compromised immune
systems is because of aml nitrate and
crystal meth and party drugs,
and he showed overwhelming like in his,
in his mind,
overwhelming evidence that all these
people that got aids were getting their
immune system was compromised because of
partying.
They were saying,
this is why it's so prevalent in the gay
party community.
He's like you,
and he was talking about how you destroy
your immune system with animal nitrate.
You destroy your immune system with
crystal meth and if you check the immune
system of these people,
of course it's going to be devastated.
They're doing hardcore party drugs and
they're doing them all the time.
He,
he said this and he published a bunch of
stuff on it.
People went crazy.
I mean it was,
it was,
it was not a scientific debate.
It was more of a social issue.
How dare you stigmatize crystal Meth,
like it wasn't,
but if it wasn't a gay thing,
here's the thing.
If aids was just something you found
truckstop people who were just doing
math and,
and shooting heroin and they're all,
for whatever reason they're getting this
disease,
you would go,
oh,
I bet it disease is probably.
Maybe has something to do with the fact
they're all doing meth.
No,
no.
Unrelated but,
but meth bad.
Right?
Oh,
it's terrible.
But I'm anal nitrates devastate.
Oh,
instant brain damage.
Able nitrate causes instant brain
damage.
You pop one of those stages of
ammonia poppers.
Yeah,
they,
they do.
Um,
apparently opens.
Well,
a lot of power lifters would do those
before big.
Like setting some smelling salts.
Yeah,
different different stuff.
Email nitrate is a potent drug.
Yeah.
I'm actually.
Somebody talked about that yesterday.
Ben Greenfield talked about it
yesterday.
Some insanely disgusting smelling salt
that you could barely hold up to your
nose and you do lifts like right after
that excites your,
your,
your central nervous system.
It's firing lavender
cinnamon.
Yeah,
but anyway,
I don't know what the facts are.
I'm not a fucking biologist.
This guy is a.
he's a.
he's a tenured professor.
The University of California.
Berkeley can't get funding for anything.
He's done.
Rock solid research on cancer,
has really interesting guy,
but all the other aids researchers
denounce him.
Everyone else that's involved in HIV and
they might be right.
They very well could be right.
I don't know if he's right or he's
wrong.
It seems to me more likely that he's
wrong because no one,
no one has come forward like
legitimately on his side in terms of
scientific research.
Based on what you're saying,
from what I hear,
I'm like my.
My inclination is sounds like he may be
wrong,
but here's the thing.
I'm not offended that you brought it up.
He's a fucking biologist,
you know,
but that's what's crazy about it that
that's why I can't think of any shows on
the other,
let's say center,
right?
Other side of the political spectrum
where they wouldn't be offended by that.
Like you said,
you had so much crap.
Maybe he's wrong from everything I know
about HIV and aids.
Seems as though he's wrong.
I don't know enough to say he's wrong,
but I've heard enough people that know
enough that say he's wrong,
that I believed them,
but people were sending me messages.
Blood's on your hands and this and that.
I'm like,
if you went out and had unprotected,
but sex after listening to the Joe Rogan
experience,
you deserve what's coming.
Okay.
If you listen to me and you're like,
that's it.
Peter Duesberg,
send it in.
Rex Bite is going on.
You can't demonize conversations and I
don't know enough about the subject,
but I listened to.
That guy's take on it and it's fuel for
thought.
You know?
I don't think he's right,
but I,
I've talked to a lot of people that I
don't figure right now.
I've talked to some crazy fucking people
on the show and I think you got to be
able to have conversations.
You have to.
Well,
I mean we might agree on 60 percent of
things,
maybe 50,
maybe it's somewhere between 40 and 70.
I don't know.
It doesn't matter.
It should be okay,
but should be totally fine.
And that's the thing when we do know
change my mind segments,
most time people it's pretty amicable
and then you just get someone who comes
up and wants to commit assault truly
puffs and it's like,
I think a big skill.
We've kind of had to learn this because
Nikee jared knows,
um,
when we first had guests,
if it was,
if it was a guest which disagreed with,
I was like,
listen,
I will not edit you.
It will not be taken out of context.
But I would sit down for three hours
with them because they would be like,
don't cut me off.
Don't come up.
And you realize it just repeating
themselves.
So finding that balance of seeing there.
A lot of people out there now who are
open to hearing these points that you
are open to hearing these ideas,
being able to identify them and then
being able to identify the people who
are so bought in,
they won't even listen.
You need to make an example of them for
the people you can convince and
understanding the two different kinds of
people.
The trigger puffs versus uh,
you know,
I don't know,
Jordan Peterson,
you'll probably never saw himself as
even political at all until he came out
and said something that would seem to be
so benign and caused an uproar.
I think being able to identify those
tools,
not so much just about left and right.
Who can hear who won't and how to handle
them.
Right.
And why?
Why can't you hear?
Can you not hear because it interferes
with your ideology or can you not hear
because it's what they're saying is
illogical.
Like which one is it?
Is it,
are you honestly listening to what
they're saying?
And can you give factual refute?
Can you give some sort of a factual
review of this?
Or is it just,
it just doesn't jive with your view of
the world you have,
you have some rock solid view of the
world that you're not,
you're not willing to look at it and
your perspective because that's the
undercover thing with negative.
By the way,
balls of steel doing this.
Let's talk about that one because what
we got,
we've got video of that one too.
Um,
you went undercover with the Antifa and
that fucking,
that one was disturbing to me because
first of all you look like slide right
in like a glove buddy.
Like I was almost matching the guy when
I got there.
Guy,
Gal,
we don't know.
Um,
and I thought our costume wardrobe lady
had actually just just stolen his
clothes because it was almost identical
to what he was wearing.
Isn't it funny though that when you're a
slender man,
like people assume.
Oh yeah,
I can get away with so much crap.
Weird.
Yeah.
Well,
what is it about slender people?
There's something there,
right?
Like what is it about slender people
that are almost always left wing
weakness?
Whoa.
You think so?
Sorry.
Could same.
They see the American flag is right
wing.
They see this.
This.
You might still be the Third Reich.
Hm?
Can I say third wreck?
I don't even know what it is right now.
I don't know.
I don't know what else and designs.
Check them out on it.
It's actually really nice.
Veteran your is that steel?
Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
Guy makes them.
That's it.
I can usually.
I can usually tell when someone's
approaching us,
if they're friendly or fell by their
posture and their body size guy walks in
your body size.
I'm like,
oh,
that's probably a friendly guy.
Like a queer looking at hundred and 40
pound man like myself.
Approaches and like,
ah,
we got to get out of dodge.
He has a shank or screwdriver.
The biggest passing out solid shotguns
and our goal.
I know it.
I know.
I did know because I was like,
I had done two and now I get made every
time I go out after you know,
you dress with the tranny and you need
to be Wendy Davis.
My wig flies off.
She still goes along with it.
I'm on every message.
You got to go in there and a technical
level also didn't want to pull the seal
team six Michigan between Wednesday and
Friday shelf.
So it's true.
But what happened is then when you were
in,
you wanted to go back.
That's true.
I was just.
How did it get psyched to explain to me
how it got set up,
how you did it?
Like what,
what,
what was the meeting balls of stuff.
Uh,
well,
I mean these kind of.
These things are much different than the
Burlington Vermont kind of gigs.
I mean that was a throwaway.
This one took months of planning is
wrench to Britain to especially to a,
to infiltrating the back end of Antifa
red and red.
We call them regional.
We have a guy who does research for us.
Uh,
don't,
don't make an,
I won't get into
anything specific,
but he is the high level professor.
Okay.
He has a,
he has a 650 something pound squat.
You'd like Bain in real life and a
brilliant.
He was the one who found the salon
pedophile.
That's why we broke that pedophile
article.
Yeah.
We were the first ones to write about
how he was currently actively a
pedophile.
He sent it to me within 10 minutes,
but he's the man of the chairman of gay
currently out.
I wasn't a practicing pedophile,
right?
No,
he was.
He was.
He talked about grooming and all that
stuff and we wrote about it.
Yeah.
Really double down on it today.
And then three more articles.
Yeah.
Anyway,
the point is registered as Reggie does.
Brilliant.
Remove those articles.
I don't know,
maybe they did,
but they did like two or three,
but Reggie is a brilliant researcher.
And so at this point,
explain that though,
because you were glossing over this for
people that are just listening.
Please explain like what that was like,
those articles.
Uh,
sorry.
Yeah.
We're starting off with a salon.com.
What was their first articles?
I'm a pedophile,
but I'm not a monster.
And it was talking about how you know,
the way to deal with us,
and again,
not to stigmatize us.
I'm like,
listen,
I'm sorry.
To a certain point,
I'm empathetic,
but we send you to therapy.
You still want to have sex with kids,
we take you out of the village.
We shoot you.
We can't take that risk.
Sorry.
That's it.
Um,
so he was like,
I'm not a monster.
And talked about how his struggles with
his family.
Okay.
You can kind of understand it.
But then Reggie did some research.
We found all of his online message board
is pseudonyms,
is usernames and coded language about
grooming,
grooming me,
like your grooming kids online.
So we found all of it and we released an
article on it and then salon released
another article where he responded and
didn't call us up by name.
It was like my week in the right wing
hates fear and they rated it on salon,
like we're the bad guys because we found
out that you're grooming children and
they released a few and we're like,
we just realized,
okay,
this is the thing,
kinda like hormone blockers for kids'
salons.
Cool.
With an active file.
Let's move on now we're not going to do
it.
There's no more convincing to be done
here.
So red was the one who found it in.
Reggie was the one who infiltrated a lot
of the antifa groups,
you know,
that that's not his real name,
but he has so many.
This guy's just brilliant.
So he had been doing research on the
back end,
uh,
upon request and was so good.
So we had all this research.
We knew who these people were.
We kind of knew what they were planning
with Ben Shapiro going into Utah.
Um,
as a matter of fact,
we were going to go to Berkeley right
before that,
but then last minute we found out that
they weren't going to do it because we
know where they meet.
We run their cryptic apps where they
would text you.
So as these apps that you would
download,
like I don't know if we're allowed.
Are we allowed to say that?
I don't know.
I think yeah,
the FBI came to us for information
afterwards,
like,
Oh yeah,
we were tracking these.
There were arrests made a because of
your undercover thing will arrest,
made on the people seen undercover same
people.
So they committed crimes again later
that day and were arrested.
So the same person who handed him a
shank later that day assaulted,
so the rest of so.
So Reggie gets you the information and
then you how do you make contact with
these people?
We will be part of their facebook
grouping.
So we found out where they wanted to
meet.
When I'm went aware and we showed up to
campus and I walk in as
Jason Antifa person new to the
organization,
say I want to be involved glue content
and that's all it takes on context slide
blue contexts.
Just because we're on a budget,
we need to disguise.
So why?
Why do you need to disguise?
You didn't think you could slip up.
You thought people would recognize it a
bit.
We could have been on their radar,
but then now they tried to find this in
a,
in a,
in Austin and to put it on posters,
we tape the interview with Tim Kennedy
and they were passing out flyers just
when you get waterboarded no,
no.
That was another time that would much
rather than whining.
Yeah,
he did.
He did.
That was no joke.
And I'd rather do that than the CNN 16
hour live stream.
That's not a joke.
I'd rather be waterboarded.
But anyways.
Good enough.
Dot.
Yeah.
So we show up this coffee house there me
starbucks on campus
where he just put me to starbucks.
So I found him met up.
He gives me the cryptic messaging APP a.
was it a he or she?
Did you find out?
We don't know.
I was sure it was a heat because it was
a wedding band in this shit up zero zero
sitting there with his wedding band,
a iphone seven and is brought on the
side.
It gives me the APP and says,
we'll see you tomorrow.
So I say,
okay,
see you.
Then he gives me full communication.
They did roll call,
roll call and said,
okay everyone roll call.
We've got Jason and the group like,
yeah,
it's like fire bird fibered uh,
well they went down to like all these,
like firebird and rogue two in flame
thrower nine.
And then there was,
will,
will name feral family fund immediately
because I wasted so swiftly.
We'll.
It's so easy to find.
How could you figure out who will was?
Well,
because the phone numbers are also
listed.
It's encrypted messaging APP doesn't
lie,
take screenshots,
but it turns out if you have another
phone you can take a photo of your
screen.
She's a physical camera,
but they didn't seem to work out this
kink in the plans.
But the snapchat thing,
when people are sending Dick Pics,
like normal going to see it.
No one's going to see what you can't
say.
You can't do screenshots.
It just informs the person,
which is so much worse than if someone
actually took it.
It's like,
that just makes it worse for everybody
to take a photo of it with another
camera.
Like you said.
I'm sorry.
So,
so go ahead.
So all these people role playing there,
there in dungeons and dragon.
Exactly.
So we,
uh,
we go back to her hotel,
get ready for the next day,
uh,
and show up on campus where they're
supposed to,
to,
to meet up and get to your nervous as
hell because he's like,
I was more nervous the day before
because I didn't know what I was walking
out short.
Is it want to play it first?
And they're all like 30 seconds.
Okay.
It's about to license from a,
from Antifa for which one do you want me
to start with our,
the
producer around
these people.
So different than me.
They were openly advocating violence and
they were openly.
They were offering to give you a gun?
Not at first.
Not at first because you actually said
the funny part before you said we got
into a fight and you said this is not my
job description.
And I said it is exactly in your job
description.
You have to go do this right now.
And uh,
we,
we had security in everything,
but I remember you were really.
And then after the clips,
you'll see after they gave you the knife
and we were filing reports with the cops
at that point.
He goes,
I'm going to go back in.
I think it can really mess with him.
Like,
no,
you can't.
They just handed you a prison shank and
told you they had a sawed off shotgun.
You can't go back in there.
So once he was in it,
we had to rein him back.
It was like a little little jewelry a
couple times crazy.
A little crazy.
Okay.
So let's play this.
This is my meeting.
It's almost like product placement needs
a guy.
This is a guy I think.
Alright,
play it.
This is telling you how to show up.
Tactics
cannot prepare for what we're planning.
I have a toolbox full of shit.
Did you bring your gun on the border?
Yeah,
I thought so when I showed up this one.
But you know that Jamie is one where
they handed jared was an ice pick he
said or what was it?
It was an ice pick.
It.
It was a sharp point in but it was like
a screwdriver to Ak is coming.
Okay.
So here it is.
I think they were lying.
Excellent.
Tell me how like I can procure my own k
bars.
We go
five inches or so.
It's just you strap it on your leg.
Sponsor of Antifa.
Now by the way,
really shit down here.
Okay.
So what they're doing is,
first of all,
that person never stabbed anybody in
their fucking life.
Right?
So these are dorks and what they're
doing is they're deciding now they're
going to take action and they're going
to enlist the aid of a bunch of other
people.
Did you think at that point in time like
maybe these people are looking for
suckers that are willing to do fucked up
shit for them stabbing anybody?
I absolutely.
When I showed up,
I met.
There was like four.
Then when I got there they were all
running late.
The socialists were all running late,
late
show time.
And one of them actually said a
sweetheart there.
Honeybee was like,
yeah,
that's the beauty of being unemployed.
I can just show up on time anywhere I
want.
And there is a silver lining I guess.
But just eating.
She was,
she was still late.
Oh she was.
So she.
Okay.
So I get there first I'm thinking,
okay,
this is a bus.
This is a really sad group of people
because I don't know about the weapons
at this point.
I just,
okay.
I'm expecting like forties guys in the,
what they call black block,
all black goggles,
everything.
And it just looks like a really sad
social club,
so like get there,
sit down for a bit and like three
minutes in you
start telling me they start passing me
stuff,
telling me everything you just saw and
I'm thinking,
oh my lord,
this is not,
I need to get out,
I need to get out to me while I'm on the
other side of the school because Ben
Shapiro was being some of the other side
of the school and the adventure area.
So there are a lot of fans.
I'm kind of taking pictures and you
know,
I got,
got spotted some take of my phone if
everyone.
So let me just shut off my phone taking
pictures and let me just.
And I see it in jared,
like they're handing me knives.
What do I
like it out?
And like,
okay,
I knew I needed,
I needed a fast,
quick.
Yeah.
So I told them I had to take a dump and
I just left.
That was hilarious.
What the crazy thing about that is that
you bring us the footage.
So there are cops right there.
So we tell the cops,
because I'm like,
we've got to get him through this,
whatever it is,
quad or whatever they're talking about
Luke right here,
I think.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that's it.
That's not playing.
Let's get corrupted.
File here.
Go around the circle.
And they were handing out sharp objects
to stab people with.
So they had someone come up with this
guy,
worked for local ones to take to late
night hosts,
comedians to find this out,
you know what I mean?
Look,
yes.
You just saw correctly even being shown
the footage in the presence of police
officers to confirm authenticity.
They walked away.
Also,
I should note,
this is from nightline.
That was on my podcast.
He knew about the footage and the whole
story too.
I like offered it to them and asked.
You mentioned you give us a brief spot
and when they actually put together
weeks later after I'd video to come out.
So he had to acknowledge it,
but he put together a small little brief
montage of our video that took place on
peaceful event was not without some
controversy.
So what happens is to me,
what's so crazy,
it's like,
again,
I offered it to the local guy,
people who do news,
you know,
April O'Neill,
they're not,
they want the exclusive.
I said,
hey man,
do you want this to run this?
Because you worked for ABC or local Fox
or something and you do an instagram
videos with five following the season.
Oh heart go up on a screen.
So I'm looking at.
I'm like,
listen man,
do you want this?
And he goes,
uh,
what is it?
Oh,
hold on,
this is,
we tell them exactly what we had and we
show them a cryptic app and I'm like,
hold on a second,
we're not here to police.
So we're showing it to him and he walks
away.
I'm like,
why?
He's like,
well,
I've got to do my job.
I'm like,
this isn't a part of your job,
this isn't.
He didn't think it was.
And that to me was in St.
we weren't looking for it necessarily a
school trying to get this as wide as
possible.
He had a rhyme going down the street
with her protest.
So he had to get.
Yeah,
that's what he did.
He was doing Internet mail.
You'll see people peacefully protesting
and like,
hold up his instagram,
hey,
hey Ho ho.
Donald trump sucks.
He just didn't have authority that he
was trying to have.
Didn't fit the narrative.
Same thing with a guy from nightline
didn't fit.
So the narrative was the anti trump
protesters,
which is what people were tuning into
the news for wasn't.
It wasn't a peaceful,
peaceful.
There were snipers on the roof tops for
that little Jew.
Ben Shapiro.
This was two weeks after.
He's a.
he's a smart man,
a little bastard I love,
but he's like,
I could see how he pisses people off.
But he's brilliant.
He's very,
very smart because my first lawyer
negotiating my contracts,
he wasn't even entertainment lawyers had
been.
You got a lot of vowels and your last
name and I have a contract with money at
play.
Can you help me with anything?
I think I can do it.
And that's how we became friends.
I was 18.
That's hilarious.
So this is this.
I mean this is the heat of the ANTIFA
fight.
Last summer I ran up to Berkeley,
they were really specifically about
antifa trying to downplay the violence
and the,
the undercurrent that I've seen given
that up,
they seem to have accepted the fact that
there's a lot of times,
some of them,
but I think this,
I mean I hate not to toot our own horn,
but I think things like this and that
got what 15 million plays on facebook
and a few million on,
on,
uh,
on Youtube.
And the reason we got more mileage
because the news refused to cover it.
And then was it the dean?
Someone.
There's some student activities advisor
released the official statement saying
nothing happened.
And so we called him.
So that was a followup call member
listening to a Washington,
what we made up something Washington
Harold or something.
She was like,
oh,
it was a really stupid name.
I know what it was.
And we asked who made the statement that
this was entirely peaceful because
honeybee.
He said he's speaking on behalf of the
police but never actually quoted a name.
So he was,
we figured out very quickly he's
speaking on behalf of himself and he was
opinions.
We found out he was actually a delegate
or some.
She was actually officially involved
with holistic statement.
Yeah.
Ties to Clinton.
He was,
he was a Clinton staffer,
supportive and for this like open,
supportive.
And it's very confusing.
It's like,
do you know this?
You've got like professors hitting
people in the head with bike locks.
Like this sounds absurd,
but it's true.
It's not a wise group.
This is nuts.
This is not a smartly organized refusal
of some crazy power structure.
These are.
This is chaos,
right?
It's your question earlier.
Yeah,
I do think they were.
I think they prey on losers of society
to become part of that.
There were so quick to welcome me in
because they need the numbers and
they're willing to accept anybody.
There was no filtration system.
I've got to say that if that was a real
faction of anti,
that's the sad.
It's fucking faction that that doesn't
matter.
Case and you're,
you're as bad as anybody tell them later
that.
So Honeybee got arrested for tasting
your guy,
tasing a guy the same.
Who she taze know the guy sucker punched
a different guy.
Something happened.
There was a desktop.
Are you dot gender?
No,
God,
I would never do that.
Never.
Honeybee was actually,
they're not my character.
Honeybee was the late socialist.
Got Arrested for chasing the dude.
And then after jail was texting.
You remember that she wanted her knife
back.
Oh my God.
Does she know the picture?
Because I texted a picture of me sitting
next to two Shapiro.
Full getup.
Flipping them the bird.
You texted them a picture in the crypto
in encryption APP.
Oh my God.
I should've brought the phone to give me
the knife back.
I remember the cops who were like,
you bastard.
Give me the knife.
So next it just says thumbs up.
Oh my God.
We told them like when it was going up
on youtube,
like keep an eye out tomorrow at 6:00 on
Youtube.
So she gets arrested for tasing
somebody.
Yeah.
Then what happens now?
No heat
for her.
For all this video of her saying she's
got a handgun and we don't know we,
I mean,
can we say now we.
I was in a lot of phone calls with,
with the FBI,
obs on the premise with the FBI and they
knew that my footage was not terribly
surprising to any of them because they
were all already on their radar,
but they did ask how you got into
cryptic APP.
They did that.
They were picking my brain for how they
function because they are organized to a
certain extent.
I mean if there is ignored as organized
as the Berkeley faction or as any other
faction,
that's called trouble,
who knows,
but to some level they are and that's
where the FBI used us to to kind of help
them.
What's what we were talking about
earlier that my.
My take on it is that if you're trying
to suppress people that hardcore and
it's just a guy who's talking and net
guy turns out to be Ben Shapiro and
you're calling him a Nazi,
like,
do you see those dangerous in?
They called.
You see the Yarmulke on his head?
Yeah.
Ben Shapiro's and Nazi,
are you out of your mind like this is
you,
you're so far gone that you like with
every single one of these things,
it diminishes the credibility of this.
This whole movement,
like the whole thing just seemed
preposterous.
Like you're calling everybody a Nazi.
Even a Jewish guy with a Yamaka on.
He's a Nazi because he's a white
supremacist.
Tells you how the fuck is you,
what you listen to what he's saying.
He's not a white supremacist.
He's a.
he's a conservative and if you don't
think that he's correct,
go debate him.
Well.
It's probably goes racist.
Wasn't good enough.
Calling him a bigot wasn't good at.
They just escalated to okay,
well not to get your intention in
escalates that way.
I know what's happened to Jordan
Peterson and with a woman who had
recorded the conversation between the
professors that were chastising her for
showing.
Just showing a clip of Jordan Peterson
discussing gender pronouns and the
professors equated her are equated him
to Hitler.
They literally equated Jordan Peterson
to Hitler and Milo Yiannopoulos,
which is a big spectrum.
Annapolis hit.
Well,
not only that,
only Nautilus Ben Shapiro,
there are no two people who hated each
other more,
you know what I mean?
And they're just like all writers.
I mean Milo Yiannopoulos and Benji
apparently.
Do you realize how much they despise
each 2016.
Ben Shapiro was the number one recipient
of antisemitic hate online.
Number one.
It doesn't surprise me.
I mean,
that's how crazy it is to call a Nazi.
He's Super Jewish to get Jewish as it
gets.
I don't even,
I don't even send them texts if we're
getting near Saturday.
He's like,
you know,
they do the shaving thing where you can
use an electric trimmer in one port in a
straight razor.
I'm like,
okay.
So logical and every other way.
Like,
oh,
he's so hardcore with that.
It's so strange.
I love to talk to them about that.
Such as Jewish,
just so hardcore with velocity.
Velocity is that
Ben and I had been friends for a long,
long time.
And,
um,
I think even when I was on the show it
was like,
you know,
listen to it,
but I've never planned to be a debate or
it just kind of was thrust upon me.
Sometimes we have people on the show.
I think I'm a marginally intelligent
person.
Ben Shapiro was brilliant.
It just kind of took a while for people
to find them.
I think on the show is I get Ben as a
kind of guy if you want to talk about
this and really have someone who goes in
the lion's den and he just,
he just doesn't care.
He just does not care.
He's not afraid of any.
He wasn't afraid of,
of Milo during that time when listening,
taking consideration.
Ben Shapiro during this time,
right?
Ben Shapiro Leaves Breitbart.
They're smearing his name.
He doesn't like Steve Bannon.
And this is well known.
Um,
Breitbart is really powerful.
Steve Bannon is getting cozy with Donald
trump.
Ben Shapiro can't stand Donald Trump.
Milo Yiannopoulos is the most popular
right wing sort of commentator and he's
going after Ben.
Like there was a period where I'm sure
it was pretty rough for him and he still
stuck to his guns.
You've got to respect that guy.
No,
I and I like him.
He's a very nice guy.
I had him on the show.
Had a great time talking to him.
I think he's a very nice guy,
very smart guy.
I feel like there's something happening
right now culturally be so many people
that are freaking out because Donald
Trump is the president that everything
is ramped up and no one can be left wing
enough and I think this is probably one
of the reasons why someone would justify
having an article like that pedophile
thing on salon.com and why people just.
It seems to be that like you can't be
progressive enough like everything is
getting so over the top and so
ridiculous that people are calling other
progressive's out for not being
progressive enough and it's.
They're eating their own.
The pussy hat thing have you that?
Yes.
The transgender community is very upset
that you are and you,
if you are a white woman wearing a pussy
hat,
you are mocking people that are women
that don't have policies,
specifically black women and black women
because black women's.
Well,
I mean like maybe you've seen a couple
but don't say always because that that
is just wrong internally.
Yeah.
You don't know.
Who knows.
Okay,
I'll give you that and just taking the
bus.
I spoke out of turn.
Some of them are dark,
but the point is like that's how crazy
the left wing has gotten like that.
Wearing a pink pussy hat is offensive
because it's offensive to people who are
women who have penises.
Yeah.
Literally that's what they said.
And people of color who also don't have
pink pussy,
so like fuck you.
Like pink is obviously a universal color
for women.
You're wearing a hat.
It's got cat ears.
Get it,
get it.
It's not a vagina.
You fuck.
It's not like give a goddamn vagina on
your hat.
And some people did.
Some people did say insurance.
Bitterness.
We actually,
we just didn't have the budget because
lansing was really.
They were actually,
I think it was lansing,
Michigan,
one of the places had like abandoned the
pussyhat,
so we just want to show up with fitbit.
What?
Yeah,
there was one.
I don't,
I don't wanna speak out of turn on and
off with land place out of van someplace
was like,
we just actively discourage it and we
just wanted to show up with 50 guys who
were like hardcore feminist that I'm
against,
that I'm on their side.
Shows you that people in Pussy hats and
like what?
We didn't know,
but wait a minute,
but it's all the socialists pay for new
hats.
They just bought them last year.
Fight in these cat hats.
It's not like a vagina.
It's a cat.
It is,
but you can't have a double entendre
publicly.
You explain that to your kid.
What's going on?
They're dead.
A little fella that's a,
they like cats.
How hard is that?
Why are they screaming?
You shouldn't touch my pussy,
your puberty blockers and shut up.
It's crazy.
I mean,
I remember when that happened.
It was right after the women's March and
you and I were talking about,
um,
we were kind of talking a at that point
where we're sort of analyzing our idea,
put the economics and the wage gap and
we're talking about this and why that
wasn't necessarily true.
Now we're still beyond that.
I just go look at it thrown hats.
That's,
that's a joke for the night of the show.
That's it.
That really is it.
They're so crazy.
Left wing progressive over the top,
attacking each other that you can't wear
a pussy hat anymore.
But who defends it is my point,
like let's say like an experian or
Shanker who I'm just using them as an
example.
It would be who of them to go on air,
right?
It might say,
this is really,
this is why the left loses.
Right?
Because now you're upset about the pussy
hats.
And we mentioned like instead they go
along with it.
Yeah.
No,
we really should have caught that
earlier.
You know,
a point they got a point we should have
cut.
I understand that,
you know,
people who are.
It's just like,
it's,
it's a,
it's a cat and a vagina,
but it's,
you can't make fun of anything.
I mean,
they're there.
They're in this weird position where it
fits a left wing thing.
You can't make fun of it.
Even if it's like obviously ridiculous,
you just ignore it.
You ignore it and avoid it because to
mock it would be to attack your own team
and that that's what it feels like to
me,
their own shrinking deal.
This is just,
this is totally just me kind of asking,
throwing this to the room and maybe to
usually
I'm just asking questions.
Um,
black lives matter,
Antifa the pussy.
It's kind of all disappeared a little
bit.
You think about it.
Think about the news.
They're really not very active.
It's been like a couple of months you
think of how exponentially volatile
everything want us.
Right?
It doesn't seem like it's kind of
fierce,
I think.
I think it's faded because it's proof
that these huge grass root movement,
I think they ran out of budget.
I think spend it that,
I hate to say it,
but when we were talking about the
women's March and it was like at that
point they were saying the biggest march
of all time said,
watch,
watch the next one.
The next one we went to Denton,
Texas.
You couldn't find 40 people because they
were paid to show up.
It's like the sea,
the fight for 15.
The are these leftist organizing?
Denton,
Texas and La was giant.
No,
no.
The women's march was huge everywhere,
but the point is they did a follow up
march and there was no one.
When you don't pay people to show up and
you're not knitting the hats and given
them out,
no one shows up.
What?
But where though?
In Denton Texas.
No,
everywhere.
La.
They weren't paying people.
Oh yeah,
absoluTely.
Absolutely.
You think they were paying was something
like 900,000 thousand people downtown.
There were a lot of big.
Give them a dollar and have them spend.
I think what's a half a million dollar
budget.
Everyone who works for a leftist think
tank.
Everyone who works for a leftist,
nonprofit,
everyone who works for the fciu or as a
part of the union,
this now becomes a part of your job
description to show up in solidarity and
support them.
It's the same reason they support antifa
even though it's silly and they support
black
lives.
Not think you're right about that.
I think there's a lot of people that
love to march.
They lOve a some sort of a cause.
They think they're doing the right
thing.
They think they're out there protesting.
They get excited about it.
It's on a saturday.
I don't think any of these people are
getting paid.
These people are excited about it.
They're out there.
They're chanting and cheering and this
is what they want to stand proud and be
solidified,
and two weeks later,
none of them show up.
What do you mean?
If there were many women's marches after
that?
The follow up.
Nothing like you look at the tea party
when it started there was to do one.
You don't have to keep going all over
the course.
Anyway.
Twentieth,
that's 10 days ago this.
Oh,
this is the recent one.
Yeah,
it's like every.
They do it once a year.
They can gather their troops.
I think you crazy.
No,
I don't think we signed it for the fight
for 15.
What's that?
The sea.
You were on all the mailing lists,
so we're on all the mailing lists as to
where these things meet and win the
fight for 15.
Was that a hashtag fight for 15?
What does that mean?
That's the fight for 15 minimum wage
minimum wage thing.
Same thing with the women's marches.
Remember when we showed up and we asked
them the ones outside of the big.
The only people who were there were paid
I'd speakers.
Okay.
Well that's different.
That's a different march,
but I think the women's march is pretty
legit.
I think these people are doing it
because they don't like having this guy
in power.
They wAnted a woman is.
There's two things going on.
One,
they wanted a woman to be president.
They thought a woman was going to be
president and then it was snatched from
snatched,
snatched away,
and so in a hat and framework.
Then now he's.
He's just a fucking crazy guy,
like donald trump's a crazy guy,
but he's going to be a crazy guy the
next month when you're doing another
protest,
but no one shows up.
They think somehow or another that it's
gonna have an impact.
It doesn't.
It does culturally,
like people are aware of it,
but it doesn't have any impact on him.
I don't think.
Most don't even know what theY want said
no,
no.
What they want to impact on find his
tweet because it was god damned
hilarious about the women's march,
about what a wonderful day.
Those are the moments where things like
maybe years,
silverware.
You look at pro life marches.
He thinks hundreds of thousands of all
the time,
all the time.
Here it is.
Trump tweets in support of women's march
that's also protesting him.
Go to the tweet.
What was it
all over the country?
Let's say depression.
Go ahead.
Get out there to celebrate the historic
bauhaus.
Delegation had precedent and economic
success and wealth creation that has
taken place over the last 12 months
because I was female and employment at
18 years.
Come on.
That's fucking funny.
Man.
I don't give a shit,
I don't care if you're a supporter or if
you're.
If you're a person who appreciates
comedy,
that's fucking strong troll and that's,
you know,
how many whip trolley,
what's her name?
Truly puff puff,
you know,
of any of them were citizens who just
fucking screaming how many.
A lot of sites that have live punched
into laptops.
People were angry at that.
That was hilarious.
When we went to the about the marches or
the
protests we went to in grand rapids,
the socialist march,
we,
we ambulatory market is being really big
markets.
But to your point that they were.
They were pissed off that the students
who were like a lot of people just
therefore the movement were pissed off
that the union people didn't show up and
this is what's coming in the busloads,
the union workers and didn't show where
the people paid by the organization.
And that's one thing we found.
so like the Utah antifa and the reason
we say this is every time we show up,
we found it actually from a leftist
activist group.
It's about what do we average a twelfth
of the people who say they're interested
in going,
oh yeah,
someone like a twelfth,
like reggie came up with a number.
He's like,
if they like facebook and they don't
really have to show up.
Yeah.
If 120 18 we'll say attending,
it'll be.
It'll be like eight and it's this
consistent to the point where we have to
determine what events we go to or what
is funny enough to cover because even if
it will say a few thousand people are
going to a march,
inevitably it's far,
far less to run through the bullshit
agora algorithms do.
We've had so many.
Does This depend on where you're talking
about like if you're in lansing,
Michigan,
maybe,
but if you're in la,
these marches or while you're in la now,
but there are some.
But for every one that you see that the
media says,
okay,
we're gonna you know this is all hands
on deck.
there are 40 no one shows up.
You know we had that even in New York
city with the fight for 15.
And we sense though,
I mean how many times can you get people
to march?
Well,
not even show up for any protests.
You know how many times you can get
people to protest.
I mean you can only get a few of those
out of a person in a year.
You disagree.
You think people are just down to do it
all the time.
Everything was hundreds of thousands.
Like every other month.
Like clockwork.
And then they won an election.
That's different though.
The yj 20 group.
Oh yeah,
the Hawaii.
That was another thing we got kicked out
of the hawaiian [inaudible] group.
J,
j.
J 20 slash 20.
I don't know.
It was an undercover.
Then we got kicked out.
Not much.
Hi j.
J.one is called [inaudible].
I don't know why.
I don't know.
What was immigration and resist trump
movement and hashtags and the balls it
takes to be trump that you got literally
a million people out there protesting
and you make a tweet like that.
It's pretty funny.
Pretty funny.
Was fuckinG balls.
Oh yeah,
you gotta get you gotta.
Give him that you gotta he's gotta set
up whether you agree with him or not.
Just take that away,
take all that out and just look at what
he just did there.
And you gotta wonder like if churchill
had twitter,
you know,
would it be this?
Is it just that he has the tools?
Oh yeah.
Well this is unprecedented.
There's never been,
I mean,
not only that,
like he's got a style like sad,
like this style of saying things and
then writing set and then attacking
people.
Like who the fuck has ever been the
president?
And as personally attack lion ted,
crooked hillary.
I mean he's,
what does he call sloppy steve bannon.
Nobody calls them now calls him sloppy
steve.
PolItical people either and he just a
couple days ago you went after somebody,
some rapper or something.
Jay z,
jay z was talking about.
I'll say he goes,
jay z apparently doesn't understand at
the lowest unemployment rate for blacks
ever is going on right now because that
really affects you as eli.
Who knows,
a lot of poor black people hasn't
responded to m and m responses or jay z,
but not m and m's too vicious and he's
white.
I think that was just another moment in
my life self aware enough.
So prefab and we're like,
oh man,
he just.
You just got burned wishing to sketch
with owen benjamin doing the m and m
thing.
It was like a jewish executive writing
and stuff like it's going to kill kids.
Call the president a bitch.
Like,
yeah.
I felt like it could have been better,
but it pissed,
pissed him off more that you didn't
respond.
You're just another moment you gotta
like maybe you're self aware.
Maybe it knows what's because he said he
had the next.
He's like lights maybe.
He was like macaulay culkin when the
criminals were coming to his house.
HE was like,
if Donald Trump responds,
I'll be ready.
And Donald Trump was like,
okay,
yeah,
that was it.
I don't care.
And you know,
eminem had already had his neck cipher
written,
like,
come on,
like the pauses and everything are fake.
It's like,
hold up,
wait a minute.
Come on.
It's like a comic who like,
I'm going to take suggestions from the
audience.
Oh,
it's mcdonald's,
and you're like,
you know,
you've done this 50 times saying that
back when you don't make the audience.
Have you ever watched one of those?
You're like,
this doesn't work.
There's a big long pause and it's a.
But he was intentional.
He had time to post production.
My favorite part things.
How he's got a bunch of bar people
sitting around watching them.
Yeah,
that's my favorite part.
I know they're all sitting around
watching and he's,
he's doing all the talking and he's not
buddies with all of them.
He wants you to think that they came
straight out of central casting.
You think?
SomE of them.
I like,
some of them.
Were they paid by the same people that
pay the women to march?
Ciu.
Source.
I'm sitting through a shitty cipher.
Okay.
Was one of the best moments ever when,
when,
uh,
Alex Jones got high on the podcast and
then it came up during his divorce
hearing.
He goes,
I only smoked marijuana once a year to
find out if george soros is making it
stronger.
There's,
there's,
they're doing something of the weed.
I got to test it for potency.
Soros is imagined.
Soros sitting there and it's fucking
castle somewhere.
Jack up the potency and the weed.
He makes the kids on kitten high enough
that actually say,
tell them he not only said that he
couldn't remember his kids' teachers'
names,
so he said,
well,
I had a big bowl of chili today.
I can't remember.
Said I have a big bowl of chili.
Has he been on the show since then?
No,
it's too much of a liability with the
cheating on.
I'd have them on.
I just wanted it for him.
If his lawyers won't be careful.
He just hasn't been in la.
He asked me to do his show in austin and
I'm sorry alex.
I couldn't do it.
I was in and out.
I was in like two hours before my shows.
I had two shows that night out had fly
out at 7:00 AM and the next day,
well he's a very hospitable guy.
He's aggressively hospitable because he
tried to get us.
He left me a voicemail and you're all
saying that and you're like,
hey,
here's your.
Come on,
come on.
Don't don't be a pussy.
Just
chasing us around.
They're like,
if you find this guy punched him and let
us know.
We have people snapping pictures of us.
It's like,
so we got to go.
This is what we did a.
We were undercover at a south by
southwest
and and we could avoid them.
Like I just,
I just don't understand why you don't.
we have studios here and we can protect
you or it's like you don't understand we
are halfway to waco or out of town.
Is there a total or not be opposed to
it?
It was really trying to be very
hospitable,
but we were just trying to get out oF
town.
I got more hate from that episode too,
but also I was like,
look,
don't you see why I love him?
Like you see him when he's drunk and
stoned and we're having a great time.
It's talking about interdimensional
child molesters and when he was chris,
great television,
he's crazy.
That's great.
Tell like Alex Jones is a fun guy.
You know,
and look,
I'm not,
I don't believe everything he believes.
I don't mean he believes sandy hook was
fake,
you know,
it's a rough one.
I think he's dropped that since then and
he tries to come up with some caveats or
something like that or some,
some,
some things when we're not shown that
were real or new evidence has come to.
Yeah,
I don't know what the fuck that was all
about that.
I've heard that one from a few careless
people.
I'm like,
man,
you can't say that,
but then there was.
The vegas thing was a conspiracy.
A lot of people take that one.
That's a weird one,
but nothing's come up since then.
That was weird.
The way.
Here's the vegas one.
Here's what's weird about the vegas one.
It seems like there's differing opinions
on timelines.
There's different stories rather on
timelines.
There's possibility that someone may
have aided him.
He and he,
the guy was a fucking evil cunt.
He covered his tracks.
I mean it's almost like he wanted people
to go crazy.
Search warrant,
document shows.
Second person of interest after las
vegas.
She,
this class a couple of hours really
unsealed documents in a guy's name,
douglas haig or something popped up and.
Okay,
well there you go.
That's interest.
So that makes sense.
The biggest review,
I mean,
who else is reporting this?
It makes me everywhere.
Everywhere is everywhere.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I,
I would imagine that what's going on is
there's probably so many that helped him
get the guns and help to move them up
into the room or something along that.
There's a lot of sense.
Yeah.
No,
I mean there are people saying like the
bodies were fake and I kind of stepped
out of their mind.
I know somebody who got shot there.
Yeah,
I know somebody who got shot there and
one of the girls who was the ring card
girl was there while it happened and she
escaped narrowly with her life while
people were dropping right in front of
her as she was running rooms.
Ashley,
as she was running,
people were getting shot right in front
of her.
Dan bilzerian was there.
Dan told me,
lady's head get blown off.
That's right.
He does hit a lady's head,
exploded right in front of them.
Yeah.
That's where.
Let's say there's a conspiracy,
right?
Let's say,
okay,
there's.
Let's say this is the second person.
Help them.
Let's even say there's a second shooter.
Could have been.
It doesn't undo the horror.
That doesn't mean there was some
conspiracy necessarily to cover up a
second shooter.
Maybe there's new information that's
come to light and there's often a grain
of truth sometimes and then people go
there for better da da da da da da,
and it just was trying to tell me what
they reported.
Shooters that all these other casinos,
but then the news never covered.
I go,
no,
you don't understand.
When there's 50 people to get murdered
by a guy who's shooting out of a fucking
mandalay bay window,
you're going to have chaos and when you
have chaos,
people run into casinos.
There's a shooter,
there's a shooter,
they'll run into circus circus.
They're running into mgm.
They'll scream.
There's a shooter.
People get on the phone,
they call,
they call security.
A shooter at the mgm doesn't mean as a
shooter at the mgm,
it means there's chaos.
Right.
And you get a lot of bad information,
puts it a lot of echo,
I'm sure too.
So in the middle of chaos,
you don't know where it's coming from.
The mandalay bay,
one of the girls that was at the ufc,
she got her leg blown out because
someone had got shot and killed right in
front of her and the guy fell on her leg
and it blew her acl out.
Yeah.
One of the fighters from the ufc.
No,
no,
no.
One of the girls who was at the,
uh,
at the event and then dana white got a
bunch of people that got shot and
everything and dana white's the best and
he brought these people to the event and
you know,
it's like we did an event that week,
man.
I did a comedy show that week.
I did a comedy show at the mirage that
fried.
I donated all the money to the vegas
victims fund,
but it was just like,
it was weird.
The whole thing was weird.
Yeah.
That is.
Um,
and it is weird to sing country music
festival.
Yeah,
exactly.
There was a right wing people.
I mean,
so I'm not saying this as a left wing
extremists,
but it is weird that we didn't really
hear a whole lot after that.
This guy didn't give a fuck who he was
killing.
He wasn't trying to kill country music
people.
He dId this at other music events to
where he showed up and scanned it in and
got hotel rooms and overlooked the exact
same sort of a scenario.
He was plotting this.
He just wanted to kill a bunch of people
and then kill himself.
He said,
and by the way,
here's another guy that was on some sort
of psych medication and this is a
constant and these mass shooters and
this is one of the things that gets
ignored and it should be fucking front
and center and everybody's mind.
They should be thinking,
what are we doing to people by giving
them these pills?
What the fuck are we doing on xanax or
something?
He wAs on anti anxiety medication,
which,
which has,
by the way,
same kind of shit that chris cornell was
on when he hung himself.
That antianxiety medication is no joke.
And,
and who knows what kind of a weird
adverse reaction you're going to have to
that stuff.
Yeah.
People react.
They do the genetic testing now and I've
done that for,
I don't know if you've done that now
they do it as a consumer thing.
Twenty three and me I think,
but actually my doctor actually did
genetic testing where we did it in the
office to check,
you know,
for predispositions towards diseases and
also you can check to see which
medications you might have negative
interactions with.
Um,
and they found out for me there were
certain painkillers that would be really
bad that I wouldn't process super
effectively.
And then some that would work.
Um,
same thing as far as even like,
I think it was a celebrex would've been
worse for me to take advil.
So things like that,
like this actually works better with
your body chemistry and when you get the
psychotropic medication.
I mean think about it.
like I had negative interactions with a
list of whatever antidepressants run.
They're like,
do Not take.
There was a green,
green column,
yellow column,
red column,
and most people don't know and it's not
entirely accurate,
but they're saying that it's increasing
the efficacy of,
of medication by like 50 percent using
this as a guideline.
That is fascinating.
And you know,
and by the way,
that guy,
his whole family is fucking crazy.
That guy,
his dad was a serial bank robber.
The guy's brother got busted for child
pornography.
that's what whitney cummings brought up
the other day.
She thought it was the shooter is
actually his brother.
I remember it after the fact on some,
on his computer
to apparently.
Damn.
The whole family is fucking kids.
Don't the shooter?
Yeah.
Laptops that was in the room or that one
of the five laptops had apparently so
maybe borrowed it from his brother.
That's his excuse.
Guaranteed.
That's what he told the cop before he
shot himself.
Well,
apparently someone fired a gun in the
room besides him to.
Who fucked knows.
That was one thing.
The room service bill.
That was something that there was a lot,
there were a lot of conspiracies and
that's like an example where I think
people said no one had been to the room
for a long time and then there was a
room service bill.
It said someone had been in the room
room service and then it looked like,
I think by the aMount of food that they
were possibly two people in the room,
like I've known fat people who go to the
drive through number two,
diet cokes,
come me feel less guilty.
Check to see how much I eat food.
I go,
I'll go To the gym and then I'll order
room service and people like how many
people?
Mike?
One.
They'll go,
you sure?
I'm like,
bring it up,
bitch.
I order two entrees all the time.
Yeah.
Well,
because usually yeah,
especially to forgetting what you went
two times to meet or you want to.
If I'm work,
if I'm lifting,
I fucking get hungry man.
crazy.
Rippetoe ordering double meat.
That one time we went out with him.
Oh my gosh,
he's just an animal,
but I'm double means double.
No,
double The meat.
We don't do that,
like figure it out as a strength trainer
and he's also a scientist and he,
uh,
he grow starting strengths and he just
was,
we were,
we were somewhere and he just asked the
server.
He goes,
please double meat.
She goes,
well,
uh,
so you want,
you want a dollar more?
And he went to ladders mores figure it
out.
That's not a good thing to say to
someone who's handling your food this
out bitch.
But the room service bill,
that was something where I read it and I
was like,
oh,
that's curious,
right?
The room service bell.
That's my point is with the kernel of
truth in some of these conspiracies,
but people,
they go on a second,
the room service bill has to tuna fish
sandwiches and one steak tartare.
Therefore the jews,
you know,
it's like,
well,
hold on a second,
you're making a huge leap and it makes
it hard.
Like there's,
there's a plus side to new media,
which we talk about this all the time.
We feel a lot of responsibility,
especially being more of a entertainment
show where it's great because you can do
the show and you don't have the same
kind of time constraints and you can
talk about things authentically as long
as you know for the youtube stuff they
allow us to.
BuT on the flip side is anyone can get
information out there and there are
people willing to capitalize on that and
proactively lie.
Right?
And so like I get it,
that's a problem,
but the solution is not to have a bunch
of people in silicon valley determining
what's right,
what's right.
Well,
I mean it's just like those flat earth
fucks.
You can make a video on anything.
I mean if you want to make a video and
if it's compelling,
the same flat earth guy,
he's got a video on dinosaurs not being
real nuclear bombs being fake satellites
being fake really jitsu doesn't work.
Wing chung is the shit fucking mind this
guy and people are.
People ignore that.
They ignore that and just like,
hey,
yeah,
but it's flutter.
Think pretty compelling man.
GoTta look into it.
Know,
but to quito,
I wouldn't be there.
yeah,
I wouldn't.
I would not be there.
I'd sidestep you.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
that's what it.
That's one of my favorite things to do
is watch those on youtube.
I post those on instagram left and
right.
Yeah.
The hashtag.
If you just look up hashtag legit as
fuck.
That's my hashtag.
I put put up with all fake martial arts
videos of like,
I don't know how many of them I posted
whatever illuminati frame somewhere in
there that I'm not gonna.
Stop posting a man because now when you
repost them,
I'm my fucking instagram is getting
flagged with people are claiming them
with martial arts videos.
Even if they didn't make them,
they can claim them and say it's theirs
and they can get it taken down from
facebook or instagram.
Shake you down for a few books,
but they didn't necessarily film them,
but if they say it's there,
it's you have to prove it's not.
There's like there's a lot of squirrelly
people out there when it comes to videos
online,
especially people who were flooded with
clayton claimers.
One.
One person tried to argue that with me
and you know the whole mandela effect.
That's another thing.
Yeah.
Into.
He's like,
it's parents,
it's berenstein bears,
not berenstein bears.
Like you thought it was going to
convince me I'm going last because it
was because I am not shizam that genie
movie with shack.
Like that's a big thing for that.
This is the hill they die on with the
same person was a flat earth or and said
something like,
uh,
okay.
It's an easy test.
The earth is spinning,
right?
If it's spinning a thousand miles an
hour,
okay,
you go up in a helicopter,
don't move,
go back down.
If you're in the same place,
it's a lie,
you know it.
And I said,
hold on a second,
like I'm not a scientist,
but I know if I throw a baseball from
the back of the bus,
it's going to the front of the bus
because we're starting at the same
velocity.
I mean this is basic physics that you
will learn in high school.
So that's where,
for me,
I was like my mount saint helens volcano
this way.
That's what they say to do this.
They just don't understand science.
They don't understand physics and
they're just.
They.
They say things and it's compelling to
people.
There's photos of the fucking glaciers
in antarctica and they like,
look,
it's the oldest wall,
like they really believe there's an ice
wall.
It was pretty bad ass will be saved.
Donald trump's some money,
but managing anybody keeping that
secret.
Imagine someone like some high.
Well,
jamie's got round earth.
She'll tee shirts for sale.
Young jamie.com.
Hold on right now.
Oh,
do your pitch with.
That's the question to why,
right?
Like we're not scientists and there's a
bunch that you could probably.
Someone could come on and talk about the
earth's core and talk about the
gravitational pull that we'd be like,
oh wow.
That's really.
I didn't know that.
I feel like an idiot,
but I can all.
I can't ask.
Why would anyone want to convince me?
There's a flat earth.
Yeah.
What is your.
Why would anyone want to convince you
that it's round?
It's actually flat.
I don't understand the ground earth.
This property.
Too much.
People just love bullshit.
They get off on it,
there's no audience for it,
but they enjoy it.
I think they really enjoy bullshit.
Like I think people get excited about
things that they can try to uncover some
human thing like,
uh,
like,
like I think they're going to attack us,
you know,
like there's like a secret,
sort of like a,
not a secret,
but like a thing in your head about
uncovering secrets.
You know what that Is,
I think.
I think it appeals to the contrarians
too because they just liked to piss
people off.
They liked to do and a lot of them were
just really uneducated.
I mean super uneducated,
like they just don't understand basic
physics,
like just a few things.
The martial arts thing is a good example
with that,
because not get joe to starting to do,
Starting to do jujitsu and a weight
training in this world where we're from.
actually the guy who does my security.
That's true.
Black belt.
Okay.
And so he's just startIng to,
we're going have him come into this
studio to kinda some privates with them.
Um,
this guy's talking you.
He's a crazy,
insanely sanely strong dude.
It's one of the guys that you look at
and go,
oh,
it doesn't matter if I trained my whole
life,
I wouldn't be that strong.
You know,
he walked in in high school to a gym
marker,
but doesn't get some of them buck angel.
No,
no,
no.
This guy walked in at 1616 and I found
this [inaudible].
It was corroborated by mark rippetoe in
wichita falls,
Texas when he found out this guy's name
mark.
Well,
he just said,
he said,
wait,
are you talking about so and so was a
friend of mine,
totally accidental.
And he goes,
that man came into my gym at 16 years
old and accidentally snatched 270
pounds.
So this guy is anyways,
but you're super nice guy.
Super nice guy.
like we church going christian.
We always kind of joke about him and
he's like,
you know,
I know.
I like,
you know,
you can see there's something burning
beneath the surface.
He's like,
you know,
I know it's not.
I know it's not good,
but I wanted to kill him.
I was like,
at one point he was doing security.
He was like,
I could see him walking up to.
I'm like,
hold on,
sTop.
You can see just that little bit with
the shortest fuse,
but it's always amazing to me that that
people just deny it and it's like,
well,
hold on a second,
show me what you tell him about the flat
earth thing.
Akita,
show me one video ever in the history of
mankind.
Have a kito winning a fight against a
mixed martial arts guy.
Or I had someone who believed that
steven seagal was a legitimate fighter.
I said,
okay,
that's a claim,
one video ever in the history of steven
seagal fighting and I'm willing to never
got more crap than our bruce or Bruce
Lee video.
No,
we didn't.
I said he was a good theorist and he was
one of the early sort of mixed martial
arts adopters,
but the fact is Bruce Lee would get
killed by a decent flight in use and
people are like,
how dare you?
Well,
that's true.
And also The reality is the martial arts
from 1970 versus the martial arts from
2018,
there's been more radical change in
martial arts.
I,
uh,
the understanding of techniques since
1993 to 2018 than there's ever been.
And The history of martial arts and
Bruce Lee was responsible for a big
shift from 1970 to the ufc.
You,
it's very hard to find a single ufc
fighter.
There wasn't a Bruce Lee fan or isn't
currently a Bruce Lee fan,
including me.
and I think that what he did was
introduced this open minded approach to
martial arts.
Right?
Taking what's useful from boxing,
from wrestling.
I mean,
look,
you enter the dragon,
he's doing an arm bar.
Know he killed somebody killed chuck
norris with.
Again,
it wasn't the best,
but I understand what you're saying,
but he's doing weird stuff.
He's doing.
He's eight.
He obviously wasn't a black belt in
jujitsu.
You know,
what's the,
what we talked about,
what people got really mad at is they
were saying he would cream anybody like
in your class.
And so I said,
well hold on.
He's two inches shorter and 25 pounds
lighter than knock.
Hey jared,
and so we had not get jared and the
Bruce Lee punch is coming and people
were furious.
He's 25 pounds heavier and two inches
taller.
That's an idea as to how small of a man
this is.
It's just not dealing with.
It doesn't mean that he didn't write a
good towel,
didn't write a good book.
The book's great,
but it's also
a plagiarized.
He told really passages in full without
any accreditation at all and took,
and I don't want to say it in a bad way
because I think what he was trying to do
was just like his whole style.
He just took big chunks of books on
boxing and other different martial arts
and took verbatim passages from that.
Maybe plagiarizing is not the right word
because what is what he did was like a
collection of martial arts technique and
so one of the things he did see if you
could have to follow me and he was.
He wasn't an author.
You know what he was.
He was a martial artist and he was
collecting different writings on
different styles.
See a Bruce Lee,
gee,
the tao tao of jeet kune doe.
I'm plagiarized passages and again,
I'm a giant Bruce Lee fan.
I'm not shitting on him but,
but um,
I think it's also very important.
I owned the tao of jeet kune do.
I think it's very important that he did
collect these important works on
different martial arts and he was the
first dude when I first started out
doing martial arts.
when I was doing taekwondo.
You had to just do taekwondo.
When I branched out and started doing
muay thai and kickboxing,
they were very against it.
A lot of the traditionalist was very
against it,
very against trying out other
techniques.
They just didn't,
they just didn't think it was necessary.
And I was like,
that's crazy.
I've sparred with these guys getting
kicked in the legs.
It's fucking aWful.
I'm going to learn how to do this.
You guys.
I'm not,
I'm not gonna not learn this.
Somebody kicked my leg once.
I was like,
oh yeah,
okay.
That's okay.
We got,
we got a new thing to change this,
like I got to learn that same thing with
jujitsu.
As soon as I did jujitsu,
I was like,
I know how to fight.
I got fucking raped.
I mean literally like ragdoll by some
guy who is exactly the same size as me.
Like,
oh,
okay,
now I got to learn this because there's
no fucking way I can go through life
thinking I know how to fight,
why this guy's out there.
Okay.
It was a purple belt too.
It wasn't even like,
you know,
it wasn't bigger than me.
It was like close to my age.
He killed me.
And then even your,
I mean,
you're a black belt,
you're accomplished.
And then you roll someone like I rolled
with,
I'm fortunate enough to have some good
guys because I travel and you'll be
like,
oh,
okay,
here's a black belt.
This guy's kicking my ass.
And then it rolled with the worst I've
ever had in my life.
Nice guy.
So please don't mistake.
This was lucas late jay.
Um,
he was not flow like I've rolled with
marcelo garcia.
We've had boucher come.
And gabriel vela cyborg,
like all these different cities guys,
but lucas late,
I think it was just like if you're a
bigger guy and you go and you roll with
them and he actually accidentally,
he just,
he did a collar,
pole was key.
It was so hard.
I put my hand out to post and I popped
my shoulder out of the socket.
Oh,
the first 10 seconds.
And so then he gets my back and I was
able to.
But you can see.
And the tape,
I don't know if I still have it,
I'm doing this to turn your shoulder
back in and it was so fast.
I was like,
oh.
So that's what that's like because my
slo was so nice where they can get more,
more,
more pressure,
more pressure.
Because you always,
you never want to hurt the black.
Right?
RIght.
No,
there's no chance you.
I mean,
you could hurt them,
right?
You don't want to go agro on them.
Right.
Because these guys,
people want to take their head off,
you know what I mean?
And so you don't want to be that,
but late shay was just super
nice.
But pop my shoulder on 12 seconds,
just the guys that are like that.
They roll hard or they don't roll it
all,
you know,
it,
it.
I don't even know.
That was hard.
I think it was so swift from timer went
off and it was a basic.
He was sitting and just grab the collar
and just just like,
just pull.
That's it.
I guess you're kind of expecting that
go.
Toronto will make dragon will know.
Boom.
Oldschool collar,
yankee and I just posted and filter.
Did you find anything on Bruce Lee?
I started looking it up.
It's a bunch of like forum posts and
whatnot.
I found one blog post that has like the
annotated thing and it sort sorta shows
a quote from it and then says where the
quote was from.
Oh yeah.
It's not like the best.
All right,
well I hope I'm not wrong because this
is what somebody who I know and respect
very well told me.
and then I remember reading it
somewhere,
but again,
it doesn't take anything away from how I
feel about Bruce Lee.
I think he's very important in the
history of martial arts.
Maybe one of the most important figures
ever outside of hoists,
gracie and leo gracie.
It's those things where the truth is
enough and you wonder why people feel
like the truth isn't enough.
Right?
Like you don'T need to embellish it.
Like the truth was worship.
Yeah.
That being said,
it was a slightly racist caricature of
you as Bruce Lee.
In hindsight.
I can see how people are my tickets.
She put tape on your eyes.
No,
we did do that one.
So because we did him doing the mickey
rooney breakfast at tiffany's and so
people are like,
this is still racist.
He's literally a story.
Make your breakfast at tiffaNy's.
What do you think would make your own?
He's a white guy.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I never saw that,
that I would have seen.
Oh my god.
it's hilarious.
Yeah.
Well,
how about when they used to have the guy
played charlie chan.
He was in the widest motherfucker that's
ever lived.
He's playing like a six foot three white
guy playing a chinese detective and like
they wouldn't let chinese people act
back then.
Like if you were going to make a major
role,
like the star of a movie,
you had to be a bike guy,
but we send the new spiderman though.
Yeah.
No.
You kind of wonder if that's something
we should be.
I hate to say.
Can you ask what can we address?
The elephant in the room was pretty
clear that often asians are not the best
actors.
You son of a bitch come on son of a
bitch.
How by it?
Yeah.
Well you never watched my age.
A career.
His movies.
that's why I backed,
you know in the nineties they just said
put dean cain in there.
Call it a day.
He's got to know cti.
She did some great work,
man.
I'm a porno star.
Some bench
who that's more embarrassing
for you.
It doesn't bother me at all.
Embarrassing.
It's embarrassing if you ever had dean
cain on the show by the.
No,
no.
I'd love to.
Oh my god.
Have you ever watched this princeton
highlight?
He said three.
Like all american records.
Really?
Yeah,
and football.
He's only like five,
11 ton of print.
Hundred eightY ton of princeton records.
But also the once I met him once,
it's something smart.
dude.
He did something with joey diaz.
He did a.
He did those movies like the dog who
saves christmas.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
All the kids love those fucking movies.
Yeah.
Joey says he's a great guy.
he's a very nice guy.
Very smart.
Good.
Looking to the point of being
aggravated.
Comfortable,
right?
Yeah.
That fucking face handsome.
Look at him.
Look at his princeton highlight reel.
If you youtube dean cain highlight
football.
He's got an advantage of some of these
photos.
What would be next to joe?
The only guy that played superman that
didn't get like something really wrong
happen to them.
Right?
There was like a superman curse.
George reeves believes what?
What?
Brandon brandon routh just turned out to
suck.
Who's just turned out having to breton
around.
When does thAt happen?
That was one with kevin spacey is lex
luthor.
Remember?
That was a reboot.
Now I was gone by then.
I lefT the franchise.
Yeah.
I wasn't paying attention to the henry
capital.
Now is when do you get to the third
different spiderman?
I'm out.
Yeah,
I'm kinda done with superhero films now
for awhile,
unless there's something really
interesting.
No,
I'll still go see anything with the
hulk.
Oh really?
Was fun while been a longtime fucking
freaks out.
But now that mark rafala who's like
super social justice warriors,
the hall can do it.
You just separate the art from the
artist.
That's just that bernie prick.
I can't do this.
He's also,
he's,
he's just like,
he's a theorist too,
which is weird.
A socialist and he's like a conspiracy,
like,
you know,
rough low.
I don't want to speak out of school,
but I think he has a brain tumor.
Doesn't feel like a jerk.
I might be making a left today with a
brain tumor all in mark refollow has
brain cancer.
We've all gOt a lot of growing up.
I'm sorry.
I love doing as well as your interviews.
No one talks about his article.
He talks about his brother's murder and
his brain tumor.
Oh see there you go.
It's gonna bring you asshole.
So that
opens up a bar.
Yeah,
he's got a brain tumor.
So maybe that's where the conspiracy
theories are all coming from.
What conspiracy theories?
I don't remember him.
He was somewhere and it was like,
you know,
I,
I don't,
I couldn't tell you.
I wouldn't want to speak out of turn,
but I have been surprised because I knew
it was far left.
It was like kind of like big brother
government.
I'm like,
oh,
that's weird for You to think big
brother's watching,
but want a bigger,
big brother.
All right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
that's the problem,
right?
They think nine slash 11 truther oh,
is that one of them?
Oh,
mark.
Marky mark.
AnoTher one of those things.
It's like you look at it after the fact
and you go look at all these
connections,
like,
okay,
maybe,
maybe just chaos.
And two guys flew planes into.
Or a bunch of guys flew planes into
buildings.
Well,
the problem is I think they're
capitalizing what we were talking about.
RighT?
Which is real.
No one wanted to cover the entire issue.
No one wants to.
No one wants to talk about the puberty
blockers to kids and this being
considered hate speech.
It's true.
There is a media coverup of a lot of
information.
Certainly I would say sort of a cover up
there is a monopoly on informational
distribution,
right?
That's real.
That's real people.
When you find that out,
it kind of opens your eyes.
You're goIng,
okay,
what else don't I know so people take
that and then try and capitalize on it
with lies,
which is you didn't know jay z's in the
illuminati.
Nine slash 11 was an inside job and it
just goes on because there's some truth
to it and you put the problem is you
want to get people searching,
but it does it.
Truth has to run.
Your post office orchestrated the
biggest terror attack on american soil.
There's unquestionably.
There were some
taking advantage of the events in order
to pass policy that wasn't possible
before and the patriot act,
the patriot act was drafted long before
nine slash 11 and they pushed it through
and then there's.
There's a lot that I think you could
attribute to them taking advantage of
this tragedy,
but the idea that they orchestrated it,
man,
this just.
It doesn't.
The burden,
the burden of proof is on them to say
that when they did see loose change,
you know,
there's a lot of people that believe.
What I find that crazy about that is
that,
you know,
this crazy corrupt government than nine
slash 11 commission report.
Okay.
George bush,
like a mark,
rough flow.
But theN you look at the drone strikes
with baraka was like,
all of a sudden,
where's code?
All of thIs goes away.
There's one that's consistent.
Now.
I don't hate George Bush.
I know I'm probably in the minority
here.
I don't think it was a great president.
I don't think he's as bad as a lot of
people,
you know,
green day thinks he was.
I don't think it was a great president,
but the point is I don't want George
Bush to have unfettered power,
nor barack obama nor Donald Trump.
It's not selective.
I don't trust any of them.
Yeah.
Mike baker used to be in the cia,
told me that those drone strikes are,
those are designed or rather,
um,
dictated by lawyers.
Like when,
what,
what gets passed and what gets passed
through its lawyers.
Lawyers make the final decision and I
was like,
really?
And he's like,
yeah,
lawyers.
They decide like,
hey,
you know what,
how many people are in this building
that are friendlies?
So nations decide who's going to be
dying over there.
Wait,
what?
What son of a bitch?
And first it was Bruce Lee,
now it's the asians and the jews
together.
Well,
you know,
they do.
Cool.
Statistically speaking,
voice.
I going to end this.
Actually it's a little bit past 12.
I gotta get outta here a little bit past
off or rather I got to get out of here.
Can I get it?
BuT I'm just like,
you so much man.
Thank you.
And listen,
thanks for these videos you guys do.
They're funny,
they're informative and I think
especially that transgender one that
really freaked me out.
I think a lot of stuff You guys do is
very important.
Glad we could help.
A lot of it is just ridiculous,
but keep that up to what we do.
not gay jared on twitter.
And uh,
of course,
uh,
you're s crowder on twitter,
right?
Right.
Bye everybody.
Thanks.